[музика]
шановні пані та панове це всеукраїнський
форум Україна 30 освіта і наука вітаємо
усіх вас тих хто нас дивиться і ті хто
вже присутні ці залі і зовсім скоро на
цій сцені будуть наші спікери і ми
будемо відповідати на важливі питання
які стосуються української освіти науки
сьогодні особливі акценти на комфортному
і безпечному середовищі навчання А також
на освіті дорослих від традиційної
освіти підвищення кваліфікації до
сучасних курсів які на відстали
напрямком бізнес-освіти процеси сьогодні
на форумі Україна 30
знання - це скарб а вміння вчитись ключ
до нього українська освіта змінюється
вона стає гнучкішою і сучаснішою
цифровою і безбар'єрною наука все більше
цікавить молодь розробки і винаходи
перетворюються на стартапи а держава
підтримує і мотивує
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 освіта і
наука
вітаємо всіх на форумі Україна 30 освіта
і наука протягом цих трьох днів ми
говоримо про основні досягнення плани і
перспективи українського освіти і науки
і запросили справді поважних експертів
гравців
і цього ринку цієї сфери і керівників
вищих навчальних закладів і
представників як Національна академія
наук до сучасних хакатонів І взагалі
практика співпраці із реальними
виробниками і міжнародні партнери ми
розпочинаємо другий день і Я запрошую на
цю сцену міністра освіти і науки України
Сергія шкарлета
[музика]
Доброго ранку Шановні колеги Доброго
ранку шановна аудиторія дуже приємно
бачити всі знайомі обличчя Чернігів
привіт
Шановні колеги Шановні друзі Сьогодні
дуже цікава панель дуже яскрава і я в
рамках солоформу маю дещо задавати тон
дещо відзначити всі ті особливості які
Сьогодні відбуваються в освітньому
середовищі ми в принципі всі з вами
знаємо рік пандемії вже півтора три
семестри
весь світ не тільки Україна входили в
цей незвичний для себе
рейтинг життя Але
маємо пам'ятати в освіті завжди є два
елементи це якість і доступність і
навколо всього цього навколо параметрів
якості доступності взагалі відбувається
вся освітня траєкторія побудова всієї
освітньої траєкторії всі кроки які
пов'язані з організацією освітнього
процесу всі
подальші Заходи які мають відбуватися
теж в рамках організації освітнього
процесу отже
дещо окреслюю певні параметри які які
Сьогодні відбуваються в співпраці
Міністерство освіти і науки комітету
Верховної Ради з питання освіти і науки
та інновацій всього громадського
середовища освітянського середовища
наукового середовища експертного
середовища які навколо освіти взагалі
формують певний темп життя
перш за все хочу сказати що мабуть
основою і таким загальним слоганом
організації всієї роботи і освітянського
середовища є дистанційна освіта Нам
вдалося організувати взагалі перейти
зовсім на так звані незвичні рейки ми
перейшли від повноформатного навчання до
змішаного або до дистанційного причому
гідно це зробили знову ж таки під егідою
президента Коли
стало завдання переформатувати процес
особливо в тих червоних зонах які був і
ми гідно запустили платформу
Всеукраїнських школах онлайн на сьогодні
110 країн світу учасники на платформу
завантажено більше ніж з
1800 еталонних уроків по 73 дистанційних
курсах
на сьогодні є мобільні застосунок і на
iOS і на Android який дозволяє В
повноформатно використовувати весь в
освітній процес навіть втік в зонах де є
червоне забарвлення не виключно що
жовтень листопад знов таки деякі області
деякі регіони України можуть перейти на
так званий червоний локдаун стосовно
пандемічних обмежень І хочу сказати що в
цілому всесвітянське середовище сьогодні
згуртувалося і ми можемо крокувати і
надалі на сьогодні є питання до
інституту і модернізації змісту освіти і
інституту розвитку освіти щодо долучення
всіх позитивних всього позитивного
досвіду кожної з громади в нас сьогодні
є громади які вже мають свою бібліотеку
цих курсів дуже непоганих еталонних які
ми теж можемо долучити до платформи
онлайн і таким самим Ми маємо можливість
долати всі ті виклики які спричинені
пандемією щодо умов роботи
велика робота проведена центральним
органом виконавчої влади міністерством
освіти і науки урядом України
підтримана президентом Дякую всім
місцевим органам і громадам які достойно
забезпечили всіх учасників освітнього
процесу
дезінфекційними засобами Окрім цього
були виділені великі Кошти які за
допомогою наших депутатів комітет голови
комітету Верховної Ради з питань освіти
і науки була проголосована постанова яка
дала більше ніж 500 мільйонів Минулого
року на забезпечення санітарними
засобами і засобами гігієни є на
сьогодні 20 млн коштів виділено на
проведення безпечного і
комфортного середовища щодо проведення
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання ми
знаємо що з 1 січня 2021 року зарплата
освітян збільшилась на 20% 1 грудня
очікуємо ще майже 9% 8,4
нова українська школа великий проект 4
роки пройшло за чотири роки ми маємо
підвести певні підсумки від коригувати
життя не стоїть на місці великі
масштабний красивий проект і ми сьогодні
продовжимо реформу нової української
школи крокуємо вперед сьогодні
затверджено базовий стандарт освіти для
п'ятих-9 класів розроблений типову
освітню програму формується модельні
програми в і ми маємо вже і далі
крокувати і формувати певні
траєкторії руху вже по п'ятому дев'ятому
класу
ми при цьому Кабінетом міністрів
затверджено план заходів з реалізації
національної стратегії безпечного і
здоровоосвітнього середовища в новий
українській школі на 2021 рік Окрім
цього по новій українській школі
доповнено так званої концепцією
stem-освіти причому stem-освіта не
тільки для школи вона для всіх елементів
освітнього процесу від дошкільнят до
школи університети коледжі профтехосвіта
і Окрім цього в сьогодні з профільним
комітетом Верховної Ради з питань освіти
і науки та інновації з окремими
депутатами головами під комітетів Ми
опрацьовуємо сьогодні зміни до
законодавства щодо старшої профільної
школи
10-11-10-12 класи в рамках подальшої
реалізації платформи нуш сьогодні
мабуть що на рівні базової освіти Ми
розпочинаємо пілотування так само як по
перших-четвертих класах так і по
п'ятому-дев'ятому класу рухаємось вперед
для того щоб все-таки реформу цю
завершити
сам основним елементом все-таки
підготовки і реформи нової української
школи в будь-якому випадку все одно
виступає вчитель виступає той носії
знань який спроможний набрати знання а
потім повертати їх в освітнє середовище
з певною з певним прирістом і саме від
вчителя залежить якість реформи нової
української школи Я дуже вдячний нашим
колегам
голови департаментів освіти і науки
присутні в нас Вітаю вас ще раз
в співпраці з інститутами післядипломної
педагогічної освіти там на сьогодні
сконцентровані всі знання методичні
знання щодо пілотування 1-4 класу ми
готові до нового пілоту і експерименту
по 5-9 класу Я дуже вдячний колегам за
організовану
процедуру підвищення кваліфікації
основним елементом також підтверджені
якості вчителя є сертифікація ми маємо
за 2020 рік
91191 у нас вчитель який добровільно
пройшов сертифікацію при цьому отримав
можливість 20% до заробітної плати
офіційно легально додати як
підтвердження своєї спроможності фахової
спроможності зануреності в реформу школи
в підвищення фахової майстерності це не
говорить що ми когось обмежуємо було
було в нас 1,536 заяв але дійшли
сертифікувались лише 91 на сьогодні мені
здається там Біля трьох тисяч заяв ми
рухаємось в тому контексті сертифікації
який передбачено нормативними
документами більш того хочу сказати що
до кінця
дії обмежень адаптивного карантину
пандемічних умов в нас встановлена
Кабінетом міністрів України підтверджено
20% доплата до над рівень мінімальної
для медиків які працюють в закладах
загальної середньої освіти дуже яскравою
красивою і сучасною є реформа шкільного
харчування яка відбувається під
патронатом першої леді України пані
Олени зеленської а в урядом України в
минулому році було виділено більше ніж
400 мільйонів гривень на реформу на
харчоблокі а також місцевими органами
Десь ще 100 мільйонів як
співфінансування було
Додано до цієї
субвенції і на сьогодні 1809 закладів
там можливо сказати що це мало але це
лише перші кроки 1809 шкіл повністю
реформовані харчоблоки це є надсучасні
під санітарні регламент під нове шкільне
меню і дуже приємно спостерігати коли ми
звикли до певних традиційних
особливостей шкільних їдалень але На
сьогодні це зовсім інші
комфортні умови отримання їжі гарячого
харчування безпечного харчування
формування здорових звичок на майбутнє і
це насамперед дуже важливо
окремої категорію по школі є підручники
дякуючи голові комітету комітету
Верховної Ради з питань освіти науки
інновації ми провели комітетські
слухання з підготовки підручників Ви
знаєте скільки іде
старої моделі підготовки підручників
скільки ми отримали певного негативу там
помилки там неякісний відбір там є
боротьба між двома авторами там ще інші
якісь проблеми які виникали в цьому
середовищі але на сьогодні Мені здається
ми принаймні наблизили модель підготовки
підручників до того стану коли ми навіть
із освітніми мабутьсменом ми
дійшли
згоди щодо
процедурнової процедури запуску
підготовки підручників і друку
підручників і відбору підручників Я
думаю що директор інституту модернізації
змісту освіти буде мати свою
свій виступи він детально розкаже і
відповість на запитання
цифровізація освіти
централізація освіти на сьогодні є Тім
елементом який дозволяє нам занурити
світ зовсім інших технологій надзвичайно
розширити можливості і учасники
освітнього усіх учасників освітнього
процесу від учнів студентів до
викладачів науково-педагогічного
працівників в цій співпраці
активно запроваджена система
функціонування інклюзивно-ресурсних
центрів під’єднана система icom
реалізовано проект Я вже казав
всеукраїнська школа онлайн і на
наступний рік на 21 рік нашим
пріоритетами буде формування цифрової
інфраструктури програмне забезпечення
для засобів дистанційного та змішаного
навчання цифрова грамотність і
цифровізація всіх управлінських процесів
дошкільна освіта на сьогодні знову ж
таки в тісній співпраці з комітетом
освіти науки та інновації розглядається
новий проект дошкільної освіти взагалі
Ну ми навіть сьогодні відходимо від
терміну дошкільна освіта ми говоримо про
освіту раннього розвитку від
пренатального і далі бо ми маємо рухати
і побудувати цілісну систему взагалі
освіти в Україні неділячи її на певні
рівні рівні кожен рівень має або повинен
мати своє
логічне продовження в наступному тобто
якість доступність і в наступність
кожного з рівнів для того щоб людина
підійшла до того стану коли в нас
запроваджується освіта дорослих або
освіта впродовж всього життя
на сьогодні
на сьогодні позашкільна освіта
позашкільна освіта це є одним з важливих
елементів я прошу і звертаюсь до
місцевих органів влади до наших колег
директорів департаментів освіти і науки
дошкільна освіта є додатковим елементом
кожного з кожної з наших дітей для того
щоб розвивати навички здібності згідно
їх моторів які згідно їх сприйняття
світу і дозволяє набагато більше
отримати додаткових елементів
соціалізації тому дуже просив би
обережно е-е якби співпрацювати з
закладами дошкільної освіти Я розумію що
це навантаження на місцевий бюджет але
це вклад в майбутнє наших дітей
дуже важливим є тема спеціальної освіти
ви на сьогодні бачите такі надзвичайно
резонансні особливо це Волинь
Закарпатська область там де там де
закрили наприклад Закарпатська область
закрила з шести закладів всі шість
закладів спеціальної освіти закриті не
може бути такого дитина з носологіями
батьки дитини з носологіями мають мати
вибір або
здобувати освіту в
звичайній школі соціалізуватись і в
інклюзивних класах або це має бути
спеціальний заклад який дійсно має
спеціальних теплопедагогів всіх інших
спеціалістів які спроможній дитині
надати можливість отримати знання
соціалізуватися і рухатись далі у Вибір
є основа всього можливість мати Вибір є
сьогодні
абсолютно тим кроком на яких стоїть
Міністерство які сьогодні підтримуються
комітетом
професійно-технічна освіта дуже важливий
елемент - це наші підготовки наших
золотих рук сьогодні в тісній співпраці
з губернаторами з мерами ми для кожної
області розробили дорожню карту щодо
подальшої долі
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
президент підписав координаційну Раду
президент видав спеціальний указ згідно
з яким ми сьогодні рухаємось по
підготовці робітничих професійних
робітничих кадрів для саме нашої
економіки країни більше ніж 200 на
навчально-практичних центрів за
найсучасніші стандартами під певний
певну професію створену сьогодні в
Україні і на цьому Ми не збираємось
зупинятись
[музика]
зрозуміло що вчора був презентований в
сфері вищої освіти теж багато
інноваційних елементів руху ну перш за
все ми маємо чітко зрозуміти дійсно
багато ми говоримо про те що закладів
вищої освіти багато їх дійсно багато і
дійсно сьогодні шлях та оптимізації
закладів вищої освіти має іти вже від
губернаторів від голів територіальних
громад від взагалі самих університетів
тільки об'єднання об'єднання в цьому
контексті дасть нам можливість рухатись
далі на сьогодні багато надлишкових
площі Я думаю що
голова комітету ще подалі розкаже ті
законодавчі ініціативи які є на сьогодні
щодо розблокування процесу об'єднання
цих університетів воно має відбутися і
це головна позиція на якій стоїть
Міністерство освіти хочу
подякувати Шановні колеги кожному з вас
за небайдужість до освіти на сьогодні
освіта є наймогутнішою зброєю заради
якої ми можемо змінити за допомогою якої
ми можемо змінити світ мені дуже приємно
що саме президент взяв цю зброю в своє
собі на підтримку всіх тих реформ які
Сьогодні відбуваються в країні а зараз я
хочу запросити
на сцену голову комітету Верховної Ради
України освіти науки та інновації в
серію віталійовича бабака
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні колеги вчора був
дуже плідний І цікавий день на форумі ми
говорили про глобальні речі в основному
ми говорили про нашу освіту і науку
світовому просторі сьогодні більш
конкретні теми це освітнє середовище
індивідуальні траєкторії освітні і
освіту дорослих
ми як Верховна Рада вже зробили все
можливе для того щоб Система середньої
освіти запрацювала і стала більш
сучасною ми прийняли закон про повну
загальну середню освіту який Ми
сподіваємось заклав серйозний фундамент
для її розвитку Наша задача як Верховної
Ради підкріпити це фінансово тому
кожного року для того для розбудови
освітнього середовища ми виділяємо
субвенції вже четвертий рік 8 виділяємо
Майже півтора мільярди на нову
українську школу і діти які пішли в
перший клас саме в нову українську школу
вони зараз переходять до четвертого і
субвенція виділяється вони вже приходять
в новий освітній простір і таким чином
сама школа зростає і модернізується
разом з цими дітьми які приходять з
класу в клас це не може не тішити але
цього напевно Недостатньо тому вже
другий рік як ми започаткували субвенцію
державну спроможня школа яка Минулого
року через секвестери ковід склала
півмільярда цього року Вона складає 1
млрд грн які чітко ідуть в об'є
територіальні громади на проекти які
пов'язані з освітнім середовищем шкіл
для того щоб опорні школи і мережа
опорних шкіл і великі школи які навіть
не є опорними для того щоб вони отримали
додаткові кошти на модернізацію свого
освітнього середовища
те саме ми робимо з професійно-технічною
освітою яка є дуже важливою для нас І в
нас в даному питанні чітка співпраці з
міністерством освіти і науки повне
розуміння З Кабінетом міністрів І це
один з пріоритетів президента України -
Це нова якість професійно-технічної
освіти Тому зараз в комітеті активно
розробляється новий закон про професійну
освіту і кожного року ми також виділяємо
додаткову субвенцію на створення
навчально-практичних центрів саме тих
сучасних центрів де готують сучасних
фахівців для ринку праці
Минулого року ми відкрили близько 50
нових центрів не плануємо зупинятися і
цього року і будемо планувати ці
субвенції на наступні роки якщо ми
говоримо пан міністр сказав щойно про
потенційне об'єднання університетів
сказав що їх багато це правда але Наша
задача не скоротити кількість Наша
задача створити потужні регіональні і
галузеві центри розвитку вищої освіти
сучасні університети тому власне На жаль
цей процес
гальмується одним з діючих указів
президента Тому зараз в комітеті
винесений на друге читання Верховну Раду
законопроект 4486 які знімає обмеження
по об'єднання університетів і їх майна і
ми сподіваємося що Таким чином ми
зробимо фундамент для створення не
тільки будемо створювати не тільки нові
університети як вчора президент підписав
указ про створення президентського
університету але ми також хочемо щоб
існує чи університети об'єднувалися
потужні регіональні центри і е
конкурували не тільки всередині України
а й на зовнішніх ринках Ну і остання
панель яка сьогодні буде
остання але не остання заважливість - це
освіта дорослих Ми мусимо зрозуміти Я
думаю що кожен з нас прекрасно розуміє
що ми будемо перевчатися все своє життя
скільки разів за життя ми не знаємо але
це точно буде І скоріше за все цей кожен
новий строк пере навчання буде
скорочуватись тому це не тільки виклик
це і величезна можливість для закладів
професійної освіти і для закладів вищої
освіти тому що я думаю
недалекому майбутньому ці заклади вони
будуть більше надавати послуг саме по
перекваліфікації і саме по підвищенню
кваліфікації для того щоб всі випускники
університетів незалежно від того коли
вони його завершили могли оновити свої
знання до рівня е-е сучасних викликів
світу тож колеги Я впевнений що
сьогоднішній день буде такий самий
плідний А може й краще ніж вчорашній я
бажаю нам всім успіху і бажаю нам всім
на майбутніх дискусіях напрацювати нові
моделі і нові підходи для того щоб
спільно рухати нашу освіту вперед
Дякуємо пане Сергію Запрошуємо до
продовження безпосередньо форуму і
зовсім скоро тут буде перша дискусія
другого дня для наших глядачів А ті хто
дивляться нашу трансляцію зможете
подивитися продовження
прес-конференції
міністра освіти і науки України яка вже
розпочалась
цих курсів
в
Міністерстві освіти і науки України
завжди функціонували Ці курси без
стипендії без проживання ми проводили їх
весь час в тому числі і в цьому році на
ті всі університети які з минулого року
можна було зареєструватися абсолютно
всіх університетах і планувати вступ для
дітей з тимчасово окупованих територій а
стипендія проживання і ті умови які про
які ви говорите трошки не Наша Парафія
це Міністерство тимчасово окупованих
територій
чому саме на них по вибір і Можливо тоді
зможуть надати пропонували 9
університетів які самі виявили бажання
Але знову ж таки ну це трошки не наше Це
трошки не наше змінювати бажаючих
вступити з тимчасово окупованих
територій в українській вищі у тому році
і у цьому можете порівняти за заявами в
минулому році це було тисячі але рік від
року завжди більше рік від року завжди
більше можливо знаєте для того щоб все ж
таки
якось віщати транслювати на тій
території це ж наша Україна Донбас
України крим-україна ми запустили
всеукраїнську школу онлайн
спеціалізовану освітню платформу якою
сьогодні користується більше ніж 110
країн світу в тому числі і діти і
вчителі з тимчасово окупованих територій
Я знаю що з цього року там взагалі
просто заборонили і вивчення української
мови історію України тобто якщо до цього
якісь були хоча б там варіанти дитина
могла то з цього року ну принаймні є
публікації такі бачили вони взагалі
заборонені але українці там є наші
Агенти змін там точно є і ми маємо
всіляко допомагати або
інтернет-ресурсами або засобами вільного
доступу давати можливість зануритись в
освітній простір України тим українцям
які проживають там і хочуть
реінтегруватися до все-таки до України
ведуча наукових програм українського
радіо та радіо Культура останнім часом
увага змій прикута до відкриття нового
президентського університету і це
справді не пересічна цікава із знакова
подія для всіх нас чим мотивуватимуть
викладачів закладів вищої освіти які
будуть переходити до цього університету
викладати І взагалі як відбуватиметься
кадрове наповнення нового університету
Дякую
за запитання гарне запитання мабуть з
передісторією ви знаєте якби
На мою думку на думку будь-яку
будівельника на думку будь-якого якої
людини яка хоча б раз стикалась з
простою банальною проблемою щось
ремонтувати старе або будувати нове
потребує змін в тому числі і освіта в
тому числі і вища освіта тому що ми за
30 років ще не позбулися певної
радянської ідеології побудови вищої
освіти а в цілому весь світ вже зробив
дуже багато красивих яскравих кроків Які
взагалі відрізняються від тієї системи
тієї ідеології філософії побудови
системи вищої освіти чому вища освіта
так важливо сьогодні саме вища освіта
готує людину яка спроможна потім
генерувати нові знання відпускати їх в
суспільство і робити новий крок знань
вже у вигляді стартапів нових ідей
інновацій нових продуктів якихось певних
певних проривів знання на вичерпаний
ресурс але при цьому тільки
фактично випускник вищої освіти
набуваючи певну спеціалізацію
може виступати певним ініціатором і
новатором як правило є індивідуми є
унікуми які які вже мабуть з дитинства
генеруються ідеї ну це але в їх одиниці
тому
коли намагалися реформувати два роки
президент України ставив одне завдання
друге третє в частині законодавчих
ініціатив навіть співпраці з комітетом
не завжди вдавалося перебудувати саму
взагалі систему функціональні
університету Це і там є автономія це і
нові елементи підготовки Ми навіть на
трьохрічний бакалаврат ніяк не перейдемо
знаєте чому тому що більшість викладачів
наших університетів боряться за
навантаження Тобто ми ми боремося Нам
шашечки аби їхать президент сказав треба
їхати а їхать це так це створити приклад
зовсім іншого університету зовсім іншої
філософ хочемо Гарвард давайте
законодавство під гарну зокрема і
законодавчою платформою з окремим
законодавчим підґрунтям І зовсім на
інших
на світових трендах розвитку вищої
освіти тобто кейсове навчання 70%
занурення повністю в бізнес-процеси тієї
за ті напрям за яким ти навчаєшся це
можливість мати роялті від своїх
наукових розробок як наприклад В
Оксфорді коли там вісім років тому вони
будували Мені здається вісім будували
хімічний новий корпус то за перші
півроку вони половину корпуса Цього вже
окупили біодобавками ще іншими якимись
там цікавими е-е розробками причому
студенти мають роялті від е-е вкладу
наприклад від авторської групи Вони
мають мають на це заробляти кошти як
туди переходить викладачі точно не
будуть це буде жорсткий конкурсний
відбір спроможності того чи або іншого
викладача перш за все і відбір з
співбесіду з роботодавцями на сьогодні
ну Ми всі маємо розуміти що тільки
співпраця з тих холдерами і в основному
з роботодавцями дасть нам можливість
поштовху випускати заради того щоб
просто людина 4 роки просиділа начебто
здобула певні знання але не спроможна
генерувати і бути корисним для
роботодавця Цього вже в світі Нікому не
потрібно і ми точно не виключення як
держави якщо ми хочемо її розвивати то
ми маємо завести найкращих які спроможні
дати знання і підготувати людей які
спроможні ці знання використати
запустити в економіку і отримати новий
віток знань ідеї новації стартапів
сьогодні іншого це Всеукраїнське форум
Україна 30 освіта і наука і наша перша
дискусія другого дня форуму який
присвячений саме освітньо-науковим темам
проблемам і планом перспективам - це
комфортне середовище для усіх учасників
освітнього процесу я прийду мікрофон
модераторці цієї дискусії це керівниця
проекту всеукраїнської школи онлайн
експерт та освіторії Ольга монмар бажаю
плідної дискусії
колеги друзі Вітаю
[оплески]
Дмитро Дякую за представлення насправді
пишаюся бути тут І хочу сказати що окрім
того що я є учасницею освітнього процесу
з усіх його боків Я є мамою трьох дітей
до школярика і двох школяриків тому
говорячи про комфортне безпечне
середовище я точно є реципієнтом з усіх
трьох боків цього трикутника освіти
Я вчитель За освітою бо вчитель є певна
складова цього трикутника а мої діти є
учнями як другий кут цього важливого
процесу ну і звісно що я представляю
батьківство Мені приємно бачити на нашій
панелі сьогодні представників держави
представників бізнесу представників
Міністерства всіх хто долучені до цього
трикутника Отже я передаю слово пані
Вірі роговій заступниці міністра освіти
і науки України
дякую доброго дня шановні колеги
Сьогодні у нас дуже серйозний день і
щорічно ми 1 червня відзначаємо
міжнародний день захисту дітей і поряд
із нашим форумом відбувається форум
лідерів учнівського самоврядування на ту
ж тему що І зараз наша платформа Ми
сподіваємося отримати фідбек від наших
лідерів які сьогодні запросили до себе
теж досвідчених практикуючих колег які
зможуть поспілкуватися саме із
безпечного середовища і з якісно і
здорового харчування щодо реформи
шкільного харчування то у лютому місяці
21-го року Міністр освіти
Сергій шкарлет визначив як стратегічну
ціль і ви знаєте що в нас є національна
стратегія саме з цієї теми по
розбудові безпечного і здорового
середовища у новій українській школі
що зроблено міністерством освіти і науки
враховуючи всі позиції національної
стратегії міністерством відпрацьовано
спільно із директорами департаментів
освіти і науки всіх областей України
відпрацьовані кроки до якісного
харчування ну нікому вже не секрет що
багато років Ми з вами цим питанням не
займалися І не тому що не хотіли а
можливо були якісь і об'єктивні причини
але настав той час і з 2020 року саме ця
тема почала звучати на устах учнів
батьків педагогів управлінців
бізнесменів всіх хто зацікавлений і
об'єднаний цією темою і Якщо говорити
про ті кроки вони у вас на екрані мають
бути це 5 тих основних кроків коли
моніторинг досліджень коли ми говоримо
про оновлення харчоблоків і освітнього
простору у харчоблоках і в їдальнях коли
ми говоримо сьогодні найважливіше це те
хто нас буде готувати хто буде
готуватися страви це підготовка і
підвищення кваліфікації наших кухарів та
інші Отже я би хотіла повернутися в 20-й
рік коли саме держава в першу чергу
підтримала вперше забагато років у нас
освітньої субвенцією Це була освітня
субвенція в розмірі 400 мільйонів але
треба сьогодні подякувати всім обласним
державним адміністраціям без винятку
тому що саме вони додали великі кошти це
було 96 мільйонів гривень до цієї
субвенції і змогли разом створити
освітній простір закупити те
найпотужніше обладнання яке Ми вже зараз
бачимо в школах ділимося досвідом
вчимося на ньому працювати вчимося
готувати страви і це дійсно велика
підтримка держави і наших місцевих
органів поряд з тим із держави були ви
проведено 13 мільйонів 400 грн саме на
придбання навчально-практичних центрів у
професійній освіті адже якщо ми не
задіємо професійно-технічну освіту Ми не
зможемо з вами дійсно надати ці якісні
послуги і можна побачити що сьогодні 424
заклади професійної професійно-технічної
освіти це ті заклади які дійсно надають
нам професію кухарів і якщо подивитися
скільки ж дітей навчається за цією
робітничою професією кухар то це майже
52 000 це потужно це класно але ми маємо
з вами будувати абсолютно нове
харчування що розроблено в Україні
розроблено
ряд нормативних документів і створений
план саме щодо реоргані реформування
нашого здорового фінансування і
правильних звичок учнів це сьогодні і
новий санітарний регламент Ну і основне
це те чотирьохтижневе меню Куди входить
160 страв
Я особисто була вже на двох презентаціях
де дегустувалися Ці страви і амбасадором
є в цьому У нас сьогодні ви знаєте кухар
Це Євген Клопотенко йому з нами не
просто але ми намагаємось всі найти
співпрацю тому що він хоче нам довести
що здорове якісне харчування має бути
саме в таких стравах Тому це що
стосується е-е наших
колег які нам допомагають що ще зроблено
в державі Ну по-перше я хочу подякувати
першій леді країни тому що саме цим цією
реформи харчування шкільного саме
опікується Олена Зеленська і
ряд заходів проходять за її сприянням
залучені міжнародні партнери і нещодавно
буквально в травні місяці ми підписали
чотирьохсторонню угоду меморандум
Пробачте чотирьохсторонній меморандум із
який взяли участь в посольство Швейцарії
юнісеф Міністерство освіти і перша леді
Олена Зеленська коли ми почали вивчати
щоб 20-му році коли постало питання про
зміну і реформування шкільного
харчування ми провели опитування серед
батьків і учнів Ну якщо ви побачите їх
було приблизно 4,5 тисячі цих
респондентів Учні були від першого до
11-го класу і батьків більше трьох з
половиною тисяч що ж ми побачили
мабуть і не дивно бо і ми коли вчилися
не дуже були задоволені своїм
харчуванням
41% наших батьків
вкрай незадоволені шкільним харчуванням
є ще 29 відсотків це те що вони мають
сумніви але схиляються більше що їм не
подобається шкільне харчування і якщо
брати дітей то 31% не задоволеності Але
знову ж таки якщо брати те що вони мають
сумнів то це ще 31%. таким чином це для
Міністерства освіти стало великим
поштовхом і для наших департаментів
освіти обласних Саме те що ми маємо
дійсно здійснювати кроки по реформуванню
нашого шкільного харчування ми провели
опитування найбільше опитування взяли
найбільші області це Дніпропетровська це
Київська Харківська і інші те щоби було
найбільше респондентів які дали нам
такий показник Можливо в інших областях
він інший але ми маємо саме такий Тому
це питання є пріоритетним для держави це
питання є пріоритетним для Міністерства
освіти для кожної школи для кожної
громади для кожного батька і для кожного
учня із зміною харчування Ми звичайно
дуже би хотіли щоб ми змінили все
технологічне обладнання і в 2021 році
виділено на субвенцію спроможня школа
для кращих результатів державою мільярд
грн де кожна область може подати до
комісії саме ті харчоблоки ті школи які
сьогодні потребують ремонту обладнання
ми сьогодні маємо
схвалені
стандарти саме професійної кухаря
дитячого харчування оновлюємо
спеціальність і стандарти кухаря і це
теж є поштовхом тому що ми сьогодні
маємо такі продукти з якими треба вміти
працювати які вміти треба готувати знати
з чим що поєднується і це показало нам
дійсно дегустація коли їли наші діти
саме за цим меню
щодо підвищення кваліфікації і
підготовки наших фахівців це є
пріоритетним оскільки якщо ми не будемо
готувати наших фахівців то звичайно ми
не зможемо мати ті якісні продукти ті
якісну страву для наших дітей Ну і
насамкінець я би так тезиво хотіла би
сказати що все-таки формування культури
забезпечення здорового безпечного
середовища
в реалізації нової української школи
мабуть є не менш важливими цінностями
ніж інші компетентності які ми виховуємо
і надаємо своїм дітям Ну і друга тема -
це теж дуже пов'язано це наше освітнє
освітня безбар'єрність і сьогодні
Міністр освіти уже озвучив позицію по
створенню безбар'єрного простору ви
знаєте що є указ президента є
затверджена розпорядженням Кабінету
Міністрів наша національна стратегія
саме з цього питання і сьогодні сегмент
інклюзивної освіти звичайно має вагу і
він збільшується ми взяли такі цифри
дуже жахливі страшні це
цифри Міністерства охорони здоров'я
Подивіться будь ласка майже 163 тисячі у
нас дітей з інвалідністю од 0 до 18
років тому говорити що ми можемо
відставити це питання на другий план Ні
це на першому плані і попереду тому
створити якісний доступну освіту кожній
дитині незалежно від того Де вона
проживає незалежно які заклади є в цій
громаді це обов'язок
нашої держави і ми сьогодні маємо в
країні щодо розвитку інклюзивної освіти
632 інклюзивно-ресурсних центри і більше
трьох з половиною тисяч педагогічних
працівників які фінансуються із
державного бюджету якщо побачимо класи
то це майже більше 18 з половиною тисячі
інклюзивних класів у загальній середній
освіті
учнів 25 тисяч саме у закладах загальної
середньої освіти більше 6000 це дітей у
закладах дошкільної освіти і ви побачите
невелика цифра така 4,5 тисячі у
закладах професійної освіти це не тому
що там немає дітей це тому що ми з вами
ще не готові до того щоб надавати якісні
послуги у професійній освіті саме тому
ми зараз дуже багато працюємо над
інклюзивним середовищем і національні
стратегії це є стратегічна ціль освітнє
середовище інклюзивне і кожна дитина має
повне право отримати ту освіту яку вона
хоче і поряд з тим ми маємо сьогодні
іншу картину це наші спеціальні заклади
відповідно до тих потреб які потребують
наші діти і з порушенням якщо ви
побачите Скільки дітей у нас мають
порушення зору скільки дітей мають
порушення слуху і не просто порушення
слуху А це де відсутність слуху і двох
ушках і одного але в сумі це більше семи
тисяч дітей тому у нас сьогодні 319
закладів які надають спеціальну освіту у
закладах загальної середньої освіти і це
більше 36 з половиною тисяч учнів що
стосується в цих вже 319 закладах
спеціальних у нас і 77 навча
реабілітаційних центрів у яких із 36
тисяч
7600 це діти які знаходяться і отримують
допомогу і корекційно-розвиткову і
психолого-педагогічну саме
навчально-реабілітаційних центрах це
велика цифра Але ми не можемо сьогодні
сказати що нам треба зробити або
інклюзію або спеціальну освіту ці форми
і види мають бути абсолютно для батьків
і право вибирати батькові правообирати
дитині для того щоб засновник мав дати
право працювати вчитися у таких закладах
і надавати інклюзивну освіту що зроблено
міністерством які кроки зараз і ми
можемо вже сказати тому що буквально
місяць-два і ці документи всі вийдуть у
нас уже розроблена національна стратегія
інклюзивної освіти до 31-го року
У нас сьогодні відпрацьований порядок в
Міністерстві освіти про утримання і
проживання дітей в пансіонах ми сьогодні
маємо оновлений ні зміни до положення
про спеціальну школу і навчальну
реабілітаційні центри і сьогодні вже
оновили позиції тобто зміни внесли до
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру і все це
заради нашої дитини Щоби вона могла
отримати якісні послуги І на завершення
я маю сказати таку річ Шановні колеги
Якщо не будуть працювати органи
місцевого і влади якщо не будуть
працювати громади ми сьогодні маємо дуже
велику реформу в Україні це
адміністративно-територіальну і поряд
маємо свою реформу в освіті Тому нам
треба поєднуватися тому що і типи
закладів і трансформації цих закладів і
надання якісних послуг все це надається
сьогодні громадам А ми центра льний
орган Будемо допомагати В цьому Дякую
колеги
[оплески]
пані Віру Дякую хочу підтвердити Ми
бачили цих щасливих працівників за
освітнього закладу де відбувалося
дегустація Ми бачили тих щасливих дітей
чисто їдальню сучасну кухню Як ви
правильно сказали це дуже важливо адже
діти проводять багато часу в школі
батьки спокійні що діти харчуються
якісними продуктами
цікавими стравами дізнаються тому ми
дійсно вдячні першій леді за цю
ініціативу і За ту роботу яку зробила
Міністерство ми Що сьогодні будемо
говорити про інклюзив в школах ми маємо
з нами представника освітніх програм від
Юнеско то Дякую що ви як вернулися вже
цієї теми наразі передаємо слово пані
Ольга Коваль пані Ольга є
головою підкомітету комітету Верховної
Ради з питань освіти науки та інновації
Доброго дня шановні учасники форуму
Сьогодні ми з вами розмовляємо на дуже
важливу тему комфортне і безпечне
освітнє середовище і це є дуже
символічним у міжнародний день захисту
дітей Я хочу охопити сьогоднішнім своїм
виступом своїм спичам більш широке коло
більш широку тематику безпеки але свій
виступ Я хочу побудувати на двох
основних тезах це освіта як основний
інструмент і фундамент безпечного
суспільства і друга теза - це безпечне
освітнє середовище як невід'ємна
складова
якісної освіти Ці дві тези - це є не
просто якісь такі пафосні твердження і
голосні вислови Давайте ми з вами
поміркуємо разом що таке є безпе
суспільство це напевно і кожен З вас
може це сказати стан захищеності кожного
з вас стан захищеності ваших дітей стан
захищеності наших дітей їх життя їх
здоров'я їхніх прав їхніх законних
інтересів і цей стан захищеності є
певним наслідком дій кожної особи
кожного з нас кожної людини
яка є
випускником
вчорашню закладу освіти
якщо говорити загалом то кожна особа в
системі освіти в середньому перебуває
приблизно 20 років від трьох до 23 років
розпочинаючи від зарахування до дитячого
садочка і завершуючи випуском із закладу
вищої освіти
надзвичайно важливим є з одного боку
формування безпечного середовища саме у
закладах освіти де діти здобувачі освіти
перебувають всі ці 20 років але з іншої
сторони не менш важливою складовою є
формування у дитини людини потужною
ціннісною платформи моральної платформи
яка як мінімум у майбутньому не дасть їй
заподіяти шкоду іншій особі
знаєте мені дуже імпонує концепція нової
української школи і в ній дуже правильно
і чітко написано що
найосвідченіша людина може стати
найгіршим злочинцем можливо вас це шокує
але ця людина може стати найгіршим
злочинцем коли вона не
розуміє або ж то не поділяє
загальнолюдських цінностей
Також ми можемо говорити з вами про
якісне навчання і якісно освіту тільки
тоді коли дитина Загалом у своєму житті
не зазнає насильства чи то фізичного чи
то психологічного насильства і я не
даремно Хочу наголосити саме усна тезисі
у своєму житті тому що формування
безпечного освітнього середовища у
навчальному закладі це потужна дуже
потужна складова загальної безпеки
дитини Але невичерпна
Я веду Загалом до того що наша безпека і
безпека наших дітей загалом в школі
вдома по дорозі до навчального закладу
на спортивному майданчику будь-яку чи
будь-якому місці де буваємо ми іде
бувають наші діти це наше суспільне
завдання і наша суспільна мета
при цьому Ми повинні формувати не лише
так звану матеріальну безпеку Ми багато
уваги приділяємо встановленню камер
побудови в парканів біля навчальних
закладів ми приділяємо увагу
забезпеченню охорони у закладах але
іноді Ми забуваємо про безпекове
мислення
та безпекове мислення яке в майбутньому
буде слугувати платформою для формування
більш безпечнішого середовища як в
закладах так і Загалом у нашому
суспільстві
І знаєте як на мене ось ця суб'єктивна
назвемо її так суб'єктивна безпека є
більш потужною аніж Ось ця названа
матеріальна безпека адже фізичні
небезпеки виникають
як наслідок як наслідок
відсутності в певній мірі нашого
усвідомлення
потенційних наслідків наших дій або ж то
бездіяльності
І знаєте
Ми повинні будувати перш за все нашу
стратегію
безпечного середовища загалом
перебування дитини у будь-якому місці де
б вона не знаходилася всі ми маємо
думати
над створенням безпечного середовища у
широкому контексті
знаєте мені дуже моторошно чути читати у
засобах масової інформації про
насильство в школах яке може траплятися
Іноді на жаль мені дуже прикро чути про
використання зброї у навчальних закладах
але знаєте мені не менш страшно І не
менш моторошно від того
що я усвідомлю що нашому суспільстві є
до прикладу дитяча злочинність є
безпритульність є дитяча порнографія
наркоманія дитячий алкоголізм і дитячий
самогубства і цей перелік є далеко
невичерпним
і мені не хочеться наводити якісь
статистичні дані для певного більш
глибокого розуміння чи певного
переконання знаєте лише факт їхньої
присутності у нашому суспільстві повинен
викликати Шок у будь-якої нормальної
людини
і про це явище ми однозначно не маємо
говорити в цифрах чи то 100 чи то 300 чи
то тисячу А ми маємо говорити виключно
через відчуття почуття
кожної дитини ми повинні сприймати це
все через очі тієї дитини яка проживає
ось ці ситуації
знаєте спробуйте себе поставити на місце
цієї дитини яка потрапляє одну з
перерахованих обставин
прожити ті події які з нею стаються
відчути все те що проти неї можуть
чинити дорослі і ці явища є якраз
певною не усвідомленістю і з
бездіяльністю Все ти вже дорослих
бездіяльністю кожного можливо із нас
Можливо ми десь недопрацювали
недогледіли чи щось інше
ми чуємо ваші емоції
Дякую вам заклик до всіх подумати про цю
безпеку я маю передати слово наступного
спікеру я не можу відчуваю я завершу я
хочу завершити свій виступ знаєте я так
емоційно тому що Ось такі теми вони є
дуже болючими для кожного з нас Я хочу
завершити тим що нашим глобальним
завданням є формування безпекового
мислення Загалом у нашого суспільства на
моє переконання наша система освіти має
в собі глибокий потенціал для того щоб
формувати ось це безпекове мислення у
майбутніх поколінь для створення більш
безпечного загалом суспільства більш
безпечного середовища а вже безпечне
середовище є запорукою і
важливою складовою якісною освіти Дякую
колеги Вибачте можливо за емоційний спіч
але це дуже болюча тема і без емоцій
неможливо Ольга Дуже вам Дякуємо адже
праві
[оплески]
дитина не буде навчатися в середовищі
дає й небезпечно Дякуємо вам дуже
дякуємо пане Руслан на такий емоційній
ноті хотіла перейти до представити пана
Руслана Гура це голова державної служби
якості освіти України Дякую вам
чути мене добре я сподіваюся Ольга
Володимирівна задала такий тон і я
змушений буду повернутися десь знову до
більш загальних визначень якості освіти
і якості загальної середньої освіти і Як
маємо майже середину лекції як добрий
викладач хотів би вам показати
невеличке кіно про те як ми розуміємо в
Державній Службі якості освіти що таке
якісна школа і наші колеги я сподіваюся
продемонструють цей ролик
учні проводять у школі 5-6 годин щодня
на рік це майже тисяча годин а за 11
класів більше
450 днів багато Авжеж саме тому Важливо
щоб Школа була якісна а кожна хвилина у
ній радісною та щасливою що ж робить
школу якісно перш за все люди а потім
вже стіни і красиві партії мікроклімат
створений учнями та вчителями мотивує
щодня із задоволенням йти до школи
якісною школу роблять цікаві уроки
вчителі дають можливість висловити
власну думку вчать не боятися помилятися
А ще пояснюють Як застосувати знання у
житті
комфортне освітнє середовище та надихає
іти до школи і досягати результатів
навчання
гарне освітлення зручні меблі чисті
аудиторії і вбиральні смачне і здорове
харчування
мотивуючи середовище такі прості речі
роблять школу якісно
підтримує якість освіти у школі директор
він Або вона друзі учнів і партнери
вчителів облаштовують середовище і
мотивують усіх учасників освітнього
процесу розвиватись в Україні майже 15
000 шкіл зробити їх якісними може кожен
місцеві громади ресурсами директори
розбудовують системи якості освіти
вчителі своїм професіоналізмом та
цікавими уроками учні бажанням вчитись А
їхні батьки залученістю у шкільних
процесах зроби мо школи якісними
[музика]
Да можна було б На цьому і завершувати
виступ
але я б хотів якщо ви дозволити трішки
продовжити тому що сьогодні Міністр
освіти і науки України голова комітету
Віра Борисівна розповідали про ті значні
інвестиції які вкладаються в освіту
окрім того ми бачимо інвестиції не
тільки з державного бюджету але із
місцевих бюджетів і наше завдання
державної служби якості освіти
подивитися і показати
чи ці інвестиції є ефективними чи
направлені вони на підвищення якості
освіти і чи
школи з розумінням
адаптовують всі свої процеси до тих
зусиль які
зараз застосовуються на всіх рівнях
освітнього управління і ви знаєте
ми маємо в Державній Службі якості
освіти Ми розробили механізм оцінювання
це є інституційний аудит який
побудований на чотирьох отаких сферах Ви
маєте можливість його бачити і однією з
найбільших сфер є сфера освітнього
середовища і тут варто говорити про
забезпечення безпечних і комфортних умов
навчання та праці створення освітнього
середовища вільного від будь-яких форм
насильства та дискримінації і формування
інклюзивного розвивального та
мотивуючого до навчання освітнього
простору
оцінюючи тільки ці три вимоги разом
Можна говорити про освітнє середовище
закладу освіти і ті інституційні аудити
які проведені Уже в цьому році свідчать
власне про те що найбільша
скажем увага приділяється і закладам
освіти і засновником і державної служби
якості освіти до забезпечення безпечних
і комфортних умов навчання та праці
і якщо вам видно Добре на екрані я вам
можу озвучити цифру що 7% закладів
освіти які проходили інституційний аудит
були оцінені за низьким рівнем що це
означає це означає на практиці перш за
все те що у нас є на превеликий жаль
школи в яких відсутні взагалі їдальні У
нас є школи які відсутні стадіони У нас
є школи а особливо в містах а і у
великих селах де проектна потужність
шкіл за мала для тої кількості учнів і
як наслідок не вистачає класів у нас є
школи де є обмежена кількість або
відсутні класи
природничо-математичного профілю і ми
маємо про це теж говорити і говорити
відверто і щиро і ми знаємо про цю
проблему
У нас є школа де зустрічається як казала
Ольга Володимирівна безумовно випадки
булінгу і насильства і ми робимо все для
того щоб
боротися з таким явищем якщо ви побачите
тенденцію і навіть ми бачимо тенденцію
20 і 21-го року то ця ситуація безумовно
змінюється школи вже багато роблять для
того щоб створити антибулінгові програми
школи багато проводять роботи для того
щоб забезпечити навчання дітей з
особливими потребами школи багато
роблять для того щоб змінювати меню
харчування щоб покращувати харчування в
цілому і шукають різноманітні способи і
можливості такі які мають виходять із
тих соціально-економічних умов які є які
є в тій чи іншій школі
тому ми розробили
службі рекомендації до побудови
внутрішньої системи забезпечення якості
і я вкотре презентую і думаю що
більшість директорів і засновників
знають про абетку для директора яку ми
створили і тут є розділ освітнього
середовища тут є критерії і індикатори
як можна провести
самооцінювання свого закладу освіти і
подивитися що потрібно покращити Не
потрібно боятися викликів потрібно
зосередити увагу всіх учасників на
спільні на спільному виклику і тут
певний я би мав звернутися до
засновників шкіл і нагадати засновникам
шкіл що вони теж несуть таку ж саму
відповідальність як і ми в тому числі за
забезпечення якості освіти кожної школи
бо приклади показують там де директор
школи і засновник розуміють всі напрями
своєї роботи там можна говорити про
успішну школу і успішні приклади
реалізації освітнього середовища і таких
шкіл є у нас чимало і мені дуже приємно
що є в залі сьогодні і Михайло
весельський який певно поділиться
досвідом теж своєї школи де синергія між
засновником директором громадою і
меценатами дає можливість створювати
прекрасний освітнє середовище яке добре
впливає на якість освіти Дякую вам
колеги я знаю що є регламент І я передаю
слово чи вам своїм колегам Дякую Друзі
за увагу
[оплески]
пане Руслана Дякуємо вам а для мене тут
було ключове слово синергія дійсно про
співпрацю всіх зацікавлених сторін в
тому щоб Школа була місцем щастя місцем
освіти місцем розвитку майбутнього
України Дякую вам Отже пан Євген ми
переходимо з вами до пана Євгена
паженкова це директор державної наукової
установи інститут модернізації змісту
освіти Дякую
Шановні колеги Шановні друзі
так
це що ви дякуєте
презентацію дякую
я розкажу декілька слів Шановні колеги
про підручник
які ми сьогодні маємо про підручники які
ми
хотіли би бачити і повинні мати в новій
українській школі
На минулому тижні відбулись
парламентські слухання Які стосувалися
якості підручника в новій українській
школі і Ми готувалися до цих
комітетських слухань понад три місяці ми
збирали інформацію
про ті проблеми які існують спілкувалися
з видавцями спілкувалися з закладами
загальної середньої освіти з науковцями
з громадськістю і
головні проблеми які заважають підручник
зробити такі як ми його хочемо бачити
якісним наступні перше - це
мало часу на підготовку
підручника тобто час дорівнює якість
понад 250 днів займає процедура
створення підручника з яких
150 це бюрократичні процедури конкурси
рішення колегії рішення експертів
засідання експертних груп очікування
візування документів І таке інше за
результатами слухань були прийняті
рішення що якісно змінити модель
конкурсу
найголовнішим
найголовнішими умовами нової моделі має
бути перше що на конкурс підручник має
подаватися
в повному вигляді маючи гриф
Міністерства тобто
прийшовши вже відповідний експертизу на
відповідність шкільній програмі і другий
етап дуже простий підручник має вибирати
вчитель заклад загальної середньої
освіти і на це потрібно більше часу
наступне - це
доставка підручника тут є теж певні
проблеми зокрема
держава особі Міністерства доставляє
підручник і відповідає за доставку до
областей і тільки 5 областей мають
обласну бюджетну програму на
фінансування доставки підручника з
області до закладу загальної середньої
освіти інші
власними силами
шкільними автобусами власним транспортом
доставляють підручники і Відповідно ми
втрачаємо час і не завжди отримуємо в
кожній школі
навчальний посібник навчальну літературу
в 1 вересня
сьогодні підручник
це паперовий це методичний рекомендації
які теж виготовляються в паперовому
вигляді для вчителя і електронний
підручники які всі чули але не хто його
не бачив оскільки три роки назад
запроваджений експеримент
не призвів
до результату якісного за результатами
слухань було напрацьовано і всі
Одноголосно підтримали експерти депутати
голова комітету про те що сучасний
підручник Він має бути складатися з
комплекту з паперового класичного
підручнику з електронного додатку для
учня та з електронного додатку згіду для
вчителя який би допомагав вчителю
готуватися до уроку
і супроводжував би вчителя протягом
усього навчального року
Як це має працювати
є сучасні технології застосуванням
qr-кодів в підручнику
застосуванням електронних
застосуванням додатків які працюють на
різних платформах смартфонах комп'ютері
міністр сьогодні казав що онлайн-уроки
онлайн-школа використовується в 110
країнах світу але з підручників
підручником який ми маємо сьогодні
якісна освіта неможлива тому в
наступному році ми спробуємо як пілотний
проекти на конкурс запровадити саме таку
нову модель що на конкурс будуть
прийматися комплект паперовий підручник
електронний додаток та методичний
посібник теж в електронному вигляді для
вчителя
окрім того під час конкурсу та вибору
виборами закладами загальної середньої
освіти багато вчителів
у зв'язку з тим що мало часу на вибір
вони обирають ті підручники які до яких
вони звикли які вони бачили в попередні
роки і не завжди мають можливість і
інтерес ознайомитися з новими
підручниками які іноді бувають більш
цікавішими сучасними
модними
В зв'язку з цим ми пропонуємо
запровадити до кожного підручника
невеличку презентацію так би мовити такі
трейлер щоб автор підручника міг там в
декілька хвилин там в 10-15 хвилин
якісно Коротко розповісти про інновації
про свій підручник і таким чином
зацікавити заклад освіти
як створити новий підручник адже не всі
видавництва сьогодні Готові до
до створення електронних додатків до
створення інтерактивних
інтерактивних підручників
тут на допомогу видавництвам має прийти
іт-компанії і разом в колаборації з ними
цей напрямок цей бізнес
має суттєве оно оновитися і дати якісний
результат тим більше є в Україні вже
понад 15 підручників і електронних які
дуже сучасні і вони готові Вже надавати
свої пропозиції і брати участь в
конкурсі
В кінцевому результаті ми маємо отримати
вчителя який менше витрачає часу на
підготовку до уроку і учня який може
якісно навчатися і дистанційно в умовах
пандемії і в школі і у разі наявності
інтернету і у разі його відсутності
Дякую за увагу
дякую
пане Євген приємно чути про те що ми всі
розуміємо підручник все що є основою
того через що діти навчаються через що
вчителі навчають але підручник вже як
конкурентноспроможним як ви сказали це є
і трейлер до фільму це є qr-коди це
круто бо діти дійсно тоді будуть
цікавістю йти до таких підручників Дякую
вам
Дозвольте представити нашого наступного
спікера Богдан Ярема це керівник
освітніх програм юнісеф Україна людина
співпраці з якою я особливо пишаюся в
рамках проекту всеукраїнська школа
онлайн адже саме завдяки співпраці з
юнісеф всі уроки доступні для абсолютно
всіх дітей з різними освітніми потребами
пане Богдан вітаю ще раз дуже дякую
за запрошення особливо в такій
знаковий для юнісе вдень принагідно ще
раз Вітаю всіх з Міжнародним Днем
захисту дітей
дуже ті що сьогодні розмова про
вибудування
безпечного дружнього до дитини
середовища це Тема надзвичайно близька
для юнісеф вчора з задоволенням слухав
виступи які через тематику дня були в
основному присвячені вищої освіти і
майбутньому українською науки але я не
міг не думати про те що подібно до того
як для здоров'я нації недостатньо спорту
високих досягнень особливо потрібний
масовий спорт фізкультура так само для
того щоб ми будували сильну розумну
державу обов'язково потрібний доступ до
всеохоплюючої якісної інклюзивної освіти
для всіх
три роки тому Україна приєдналась до
програми міжнародного
дослідження якості навчання Піза і одним
з висновків
національного звіту якраз була наявність
значного розриву між досягненнями
скажімо талановитий частини учнів це
приблизно 4-5% і рештою учнівського
загалу Мені здається що коли говоримо
про інклюзію і про необхідність
комфортного середовища важливо розуміти
що
запорукою сталої і якісної системи
освіти є якраз
забезпечення
сталих показників для кожної дитини і
створення умов для того щоб кожна дитина
міг могла розвивати свій освітній
потенціал
Отже середовище
яке дружнє до дитини надзвичайно нам
близька тема тому настільки імпонує
концепція нової української школи з
ідеєю дитиною центризму Ми вітаємо вже
багаторічні зусилля українського уряду
націлені на реформування освіти особливо
в тій частині яка забезпечує
інклюзивність освіти
вітаємо прогресивний закон про загальну
середню освіту і
користуючись нагодою засвідчує нашу
готовність і далі продовжувати підтримку
реформ в освіті Я також хотів закликати
наших партнерів уряді
не сходити з цього шляху і можливо не
розчаровуватися якщо є якісь ситуативні
невдачі оскільки процес переходу до
інклюзії складний не тільки в Україні
Азії межами і
складний в першу чергу через те що має
багато чинників Я за браком часу тільки
на декількох років зупинитись прийняття
і сприйняття батьками праців батьками і
дітьми необхідності інклюзії Я думаю що
тут на допомогу особливо обов'язково
повинна прийти наука і доказала політика
а
численні міжнародні дослідження впевнено
показують що навчання в інклюзивному
освітньому середовищі має позитивні
наслідки не тільки для дітей з
інвалідністю а для кожного учасника
навчального процесу і це треба
комунікувати батькам в яких є можливо
побоювання стосовно того що їх освітні
поступ освітні поступ їх дітей може
сповільнитись через присутність дітей з
особливими освітніми потребами
що стосується ставлення керівників
закладів освіти то тут звичайно Україна
теж зробила значні кроки за останні
за останні кілька років тим часом Коли
ми проводили недавно дослідження про
вплив пандемії ковід і
вимушені закриття закладів побачили що
десь 75% респондентів вважають що
найбільшої шкоди найбільш негативно
позначилась на емоційному здоров'ї дітей
оці закриття і переходи до домашнього і
змішаної форми навчання для тих хто
проживає в родинах в складних життєвих
обставинах можливо піддаються жорстокому
ставленню і домашньому насильству ті хто
проживає в родинах де надається достатня
допомога тим часом відносно незначна
частина закладів керувались інтересами
таких категорій дітей коли приймали
рішення про закриття не закриття або
перехід до змішаної форми
пріоритезування певних груп дітей в
умовах змішаного навчання
також скажу надзвичайно важливою
складовою є підготовка педагогічних
працівників і тут ми будемо продовжувати
допомагати але хочу звернути увагу на
необхідність
переддипломної педагогічної освіти якщо
кожного року будуть не будуть
переглядатись програми а випускатись
майбутні вчителі без належної готовності
до інклюзії ми будемо продукувати
проблему з якою доведеться героїчно
боротись
залучення спеціальної освіти і Пані Віра
і пан Сергій раніше говорили сьогодні
про переосмислення ролі спеціальної
школи я
того що вже впродовж багатьох років за
кордоном таке переосмислення
відбувається і перехід до інклюзивної
освіти не означає відсутності ролі
спеціального закладу фахівці спеціальних
шкіл якраз можуть не оцінено допомогу
надати асистуючу консультативну і
підтримуючу в процесі переходу до
інклюзії насамкінець скажу що
риториці агенції ООН та інших
міжнародних організацій часто почуєте
слово
змістовна участь якщо ми створили
середовище яке дружнє не агресивне і
Привітне до дитини То ми пройшли
півдороги школи повинна надавати освітні
послуги школа повинна забезпечити
розвиток відповідно до можливостей і
особливостей дитини а також формувати
навички необхідні для для дорослого
життя тому
тут треба пам'ятати просто пасивне
присутність не є маркером успішної
інклюзії
ну І на завершення Ще раз Хочу привітати
Міністерство з успішним
фінісом
пілоту нової української школи Я
сподіваюсь що реформа буде продовжена і
запевняю в тому що ми продовжимо свою
підтримку освітні реформи в Україні
дякуємо вам
дякуємо
дякуємо за всі проекти і за залученість
і батьківства і шкіл і це дійсно впливає
на те як розвивається діти Дякуємо
колеги хочу представити нашу наступного
спікера і ми маємо 10 хвилин до
завершення бо ви знаєте це онлайн
трансляція в нас є наступні потім цікаві
панелі Отже пан Ігор Ніконов це
засновник к девелопенд людина яка
дійсно долучається до освітнього процесу
і вірив в те що школи - це є наше
майбутнє пане Ігор доброго дня Добрий
день всім Я хочу в двох словах буквально
рассказать то что нам удалось за это за
эти 15 лет построить это уже сеть
называется она школа академия
современного образования а+ это порядка
десяти учебных заведений которые в
принципе уникальным в своём э-э Роде
потому что мы объединяем э-э под одной
крышей Под одним педагогическим
собственно-го тілом обучения детей от 1
до 19 лет то есть фактически Ну в мире
таких аналогов не знаю И Вы знаете этот
опыт ну мне он очень нравится потому что
он даёт действительно возможность с
самого раннего детства определить
направление ребёнка его креативность э-э
определить его склонность К чему он
более приспособно что он больше нравится
и в конечном итоге получить уже нам
выпуски практически подготовленного
специалиста мы также единственно в
Украине наносить учебных заведений
которые получила лицензию на IP
бакалаврат и на кембриджские бол-
бакалаврат то есть наши выпускники могут
иметь но не могут иметь они будут иметь
два диплома один украинское обязательно
и конечно же либо IB либо Эй дипломт
хтось который идут возможность им
поступать в любое университеты мира
Почему э-э мы взяли это вторую лицензию
под Ну потому что к сожалению он высшее
образование в Украине но есть проблема с
ним і конечно очень важно нам
таксориентировать своих выпускников
чтобы они всё-таки получив хорошее
образование возвращались обратно и Я
считаю недоработка как бы вот
Министерство о том что например там
выпускники школа американских не могут
поступать в украинские вузы потому что
это диплом не принимается ну считает
что-то неправильно тепер Пару слов о том
что мы собираемся делать каждый год мы
запускаем по одной школе одного большого
учебному заведению которая имеет разное
направление вот в следующем году мы
запустим это архитектурный инженерный
коллегию моторна Нивках а ещё через год
ну уже открылась начальная школа очень
через год пост-технологии уже будет
запущена большая школа на на Теремках
э-э Ну я хочу сказать буквально ещё пару
слов он недостатках которые вот
испытывает частное образование я глубоко
убеждёнство всё-таки если она в
Конституции определяет и предполагает
что все равные права имеют то гроші
должны ходи за дитиною ну Насколько я
себе это понимаю потом тогда если
родители получив какой-то век или чек
или права на оплату своего образования
они могут его отдать просто говорить в
частную школу и для них тогда это будет
э-э Ну дешевле и больше людей могут
получить более качественное образование
потому что всё равно я глубоко увезен
сейчас на образование все одно более
качественно о чем государственное потому
что мы можем привлечь любых специалистов
у нас очень много и иностранных
специалистов есть которые действительно
проходили и имеют большой опыт
образования лучших школы в США и Англии
и мы весь этот опыт пытаемся
использовать здесь здесь в Украине чтобы
я ещё порекомендовал например вот у нас
проблема как согринтировать учеников что
он делать дальше После школы мы
Открываем от я уже говорил новые школы
Это с они будут профессионально
ориентированы и Ну и уже люди будут
получать какое-то начальное
профессиональное образование может быть
которым высшее образование не нужно
будет и тоже я считаю что много не
предполагает в будущем вообще наличие
высшее образования это может быть и не
обязательно И если коснуться перед
высшего образования то я бы рекомендовал
э-э скажем власть имущем всё-таки
внетрить американскую систему что если
бизнес дает данныешан то это donation
списывается налогом с налогов то есть
тогда это будет мы можем получить
бюджеты потому что бюджеты нам крутых
американских или каких-то университов
они там миллиарды долларов откуда Они
идут они идут именно изшин потому что
бизнес готов вкладывать конечно наше
создание сразу говорит том что оттуда их
будут воровать но для этого нужны очень
серьёзно Я считаю э политические советы
которые будут очень чётко за этим
следить потому что ну что надо сегодня
детям Ну у детей развивать я считают
Самое главное - это креативность - это
коммуникабельность И это умение работать
с материалом то есть всеми базами данных
где информацию и где взять и Если вот в
школах это как-то объединить то я считаю
что потенциал нашей страны но очень
большой я сам это вижу по людям Но вот
осталось добить всё-таки высшее
образование так спасибо всем все будет
вопросы с удовольствием отвеча
[оплески]
пане Ігорю дякую ви з таким захопленням
розповідаєте про свої школи Я впевнена
що всі захочуть принаймні зайти на сайт
і подивитися і може запозичити ваш
досвід Дякуємо А плюс називається
Отже ми маємо 5 хвилин Я знаю що це буде
важко поділитися вашим досвідом за 5
хвилин але вітаємо будь ласка Михайло
весельського і ми будемо вдячні якщо ви
поділитеся прикладом вашого
біотехнологічного ліцею Дякуємо Доброго
дня всім А мені потрібно щоб презентацію
показати якщо можливо а Дякую декілька
Тез дуже швиденько Я глибоко переконаний
якраз що в першу чергу потрібно
сконцентрувати всі ресурси на дошкільну
шкільну освіту бо це час який не
відновлюється в дитини і не можна його
поновити друга теза що я вважаю що
освіта - це сама важлива компонента в
житті людини і якраз тільки через освіту
можна створити і розкрити потенціал
цілого народу потенціал країни потенціал
держави далі
Я глибоко переконаний що середовище
формує свідомість а свідомість формує
середовище і це знаходимося в такому
якби здається не перший погляд
замкненому колі
виходячи з цих переконань
А і ще ми завжди говоримо Вибачте про
проблеми окремо сьогодні дуже цікава
тема така безпечне середовище
обов'язок дорослих виховувати дітей а
виховання походить від слова ховати
зберігати і відповідно наше зобов'язання
чи наш обов'язок зберігати дітей
сьогодні дуже цікава тема відповідно все
це сходиться всі ці окремі проблеми вони
сходяться В школі все це там дуже чітко
видно і вчителі кожного дня і діти з цим
стикаються відповідно виходячи з цього я
спробую пробую сформувати
створити започаткувати таке державне
приватне партнерство бо будемо говорити
дуже швидко про державну школу
сільська державна школа - це Поліське
село радовель започаткувати школу де ми
комплексно можемо вирішити всі всі такі
питання в першу чергу уява про
випускника дуже чітко хотів би щоб
вчителі і всі ми ті хто займаємося
дітьми
дуже чітко розуміли що ми хочемо в кінці
кінців що випускник має бути ця людина
яка може
адаптована бути до життя жити нормальне
життя там створити сім'ю захищати
родинного захищати землю свою захищати
свою країну і так далі І так далі от
набрали таких характеристика який би мав
би бути випускник коли закінчує середню
школу чи закінчує ліцей а дуже цікавий
цей слайд ми завжди говоримо Про
інтелектуальну якусь частину і вся
система в нас заточена Практично на
інтелектуальну частину бо вся оцінка і
показник головний роботи вчителя школи
це як діти здають ЗНО а реально є шість
факторів які впливають на розвиток
дитини і Три з них потребують серйозної
інфраструктури це
для академічності що в нас в принципі є
скрізь в школах майже чи є для фізичного
розвитку для творчого Ну А далі Все це
повинно бути пронизано моральними речами
соціальними і духовними
почали з такого Ось ця була така школа я
її коли закінчував в таких шкіл в нас
дуже багато це там їдальня то учнівський
стан вузол то вчительський а
розібрали її повністю і почали робити
такі речі в першу чергу доступність
школа повністю має можливість що дитинка
сама може добратися до
кожного приміщення сама самостійно
повністю в тому числі на сцену театру це
такі шкафчики де діти переодягаються це
простір творчості Напрямок в нас там
гончарня є театр студія дизайну студія
мистецтва
навчальна кухня і і інші речі якби далі
якраз ось тут навчальна Кухня де діти
готують печиво кожний понеділок
починаємо зранку ще чаювання коли діти
приходять додому щоб вони вибачають з
дому щоб скинули якесь там навантаження
негативним могли попити чаю поговорити і
налаштуватись на роботу а на кухні
печуть там ці всі другий напрямок дуже
цікавий це напрямок здоров'я про який
рідко говоримо
але я дуже серйозна проблема з цим бо
якщо ретельно обстежувати дітей велика
кількість дітей мають патології А це ми
проводили в себе професійне таке
обстеження всього-на-всього залишилося
двоє два проценти дітей 2% здорових
абсолютно 98 мають ті чи інші патології
в дитячому садку тенденція інша пізніше
почав розбиратися розібрався з
проблемами що вони вам всі всі знайомі
ці проблеми оце фактори які впливають на
збереження здоров'я що там 25 від
залежить від харчування
50 від способу життя а там 15 генетика і
ще 10 інші речі якби медична система а
діти практично там 50-70% знаходяться в
школі практично сидять в школі в
більшості
і якраз Ми там всередині вирішили чи
вирішуємо це питання перший напрямок -
це харчування
забезпечуємо належне віроборів
наговорила детально дуже що сьогодні
опікується і дружина Президента
безпосередньо опикується цим питанням не
пішло велике зрушення в тому числі в
регламентуючий частині
другий - це так виглядають там дітки
коли харчуються А ще також до пандемії
ввів таке чаювання коли в класи старший
подають пиріжок з соком для того щоб
старший клас старша ланка вона
харчується Біля першої години в школу
приїжджають біля 8-ї а і Відповідно дуже
великий розрив то щоб робити такий
перекус який збиває оцей голод говорять
А то це ось така річ була а далі
фізичний розвиток А це там спортзали зал
тхеквондо А це от посередині в кожному
класі поставив стінки шведські стінки
називається де діти можуть в любий час і
під час уроку і не під час уроку залізти
на цю стінку по висіти
по підтягуватися і це дозволено для
дітей вчителі
підтримують цю річ якби Спочатку вони
взагалі там з нею не злазили потім Це
все стабілізувалося з зал географією
хореографії і в правому кутку якщо
подивитися на стелю це офтальмологічний
тренажер А це кожному класі теж
встановили зараз запускаємо кожних
певний проміжок часу вчитель перериває
урок на 80 Там буквально вибачаюсь на
15-20 секунд і проходять по цих лінія
очима і таким чином відбувається певний
розвантаження дитини
абсолютно
говорить про цей безпечний
всередині теж закупили німецьке
обладнання і проводимо сканування
поставити дітей 50% на сьогоднішній день
дітей сколіозу тієї чи іншої ступені з
плоскостопіями і так далі взяли зараз це
під повний моніторинг і вирівнюємо я
вибачаюся це ще ось в лівому а такі
розробили столики для навчання сто Я теж
школу закомплектували і сьогодні йде
ротація повністю кожні 15 хвилин Діти
частина сидять частина стоять частина
сидять частина сидять щоб ми підняти
дітей із з одного місця це академічний
простір вже звичайна річ напевно для
всіх це в цілому Так виглядає школа А ще
одна теза що тільки перебування інтерес
рухає дитину ніякі примус ніякі страх а
це сьогодні голова комітету говорила що
відбувається такі жахи дитина гарно
вчилася але в принципі щось потім не
чудило а від того що в неї багато чого
накопичувалося Для того щоб вчителі
пам'ятали що здивування інтереси що
означає зустріч в житті то Ось недавно
привезли з Італії змонтували а подати
скульптурну композицію зустріч Дантес
беатрічею де відображена суттє освіти
тут здивування тут зустріч яка змінила
життя Данте повністю тут любов і от В
принципі вона так змонтована що вчителі
йдуть на роботу дивлячись на біотриче і
розуміючи що там за її плечима вони
повинні створити зустріч неймовірну з
дітьми їх здивувати зацікавити а
повертаючись подивитися на Данте який
він стоїть здивований їхньою працею в
чистильською працею яку вони віддали
день який вони зробили день дітей Ну і
ще там написано на зворотньому в цьому
для дітей вже щоб вони пам'ятали якого
вони роду От і що в цьому житті важливо
ну це так ось виглядає пройдений шлях
щоб ще Дуже хотілось би хотілось би
зробити дитячий садок з'єднати повністю
зі школою Бо саме головні речі
відбуваються в дитячому садку потім в
школі в початкові в початковій Ланці Ну
і відповідно для професійної професійної
частини
теж щось зробити все Я вам дуже дякую
вибачаю що перебрав час
пане Михайло ми всі відчули що вкласти в
5 хвилин всю вашу історію дійсно
неможливо але ми Щиро дякуємо я дякую
всім учасникам Вибачте Я запрошую
підприємців бо вони всі абстрагуються
Сьогодні я сам підприємець Я не з вашого
середовища і до вашого середовища немає
ніякого відношення але Я запрошую
підприємців що зосередитися друзі саме
сюди саме сюди потрібно вкладати і свій
ресурси свої кошти і при тому всьому що
це державна школа хочу сказати ніхто не
заважає якщо хтось говорить нам
заважають все це брехня Я вибачаюсь
ніхто не заважає всі на кожній Ланці це
в Житомирській області всі починаючи від
районного управління закінчуючи
міністерством освіти жодного жодної не
було відмови з чим не звертався завжди
підтримують тому друзі підприємці
звертаються вкладайте саме в школи І
тоді будете мати зиск Да може не на свою
кишеню але в цілому зробимо країну все
тепер там все дякую
Дякуємо і вам за дискусію Річ у тому що
усе недосказане ви зможете сказати у
пресалі де на вас вже чекають журналісти
провідних українських медіа і також буде
можливість відповісти на запитання наших
журналістів зовсім скоро ми повернемося
на основну сцену і після багатьох
презентацій поговоримо про власну
освітню траєкторію надзвичайно цікава
очікується дискусія
на одну освіту А з часом Ви змінили
напрям своєї роботи ви можете бути
успішним досягати головне відчувати і
бути щасливим з тим що ви робите
просто хочу пані Світлану дійсно
продовжити її промову а насправді дійсно
тут питання в більшій мірі не про те що
ми якусь освіту отримаємо
неправильну правильну чи ще там якусь а
кожна освіта вона дає певний результат в
нашій життєдіяльності потім а з іншої
сторони ми маємо в більшій мірі говорити
про те що на сьогоднішній день А пішла в
минулу та історія коли ти міг отримати
одну освіту і прожити на цьому ресурсі
все життя тобто ми маємо говорити про те
що ти повинен постійно здобувати нову
освіту і коли люди отримують дві-три
навіть вищих освіти це абсолютно
нормальна ситуація Ну в мене дві Та в
кого в когось більше питання трошки в
іншому про те що я хочу сьогодні
говорити чомусь я хочу сьогоднішній день
на сьогоднішній день панелі зосередитись
на питаннях професійної освіти тому що
насправді а-а в нас в країні абсолютно
перевернута ситуація в нас 80%
випускників шкіл куди прагнуть потрапити
в університети для чого цього практично
не знає ніхто це в більшій мірі є
бажання батьків щоб дитина мала диплом
про вищу освіту Ну і так далі буквально
я ж вчора казав вже про це що недавно
повернулися повернулися зі Львова там і
колеги просто зайшли в одну з великих
відомих роздрібних мереж 20 касирів і
просто провели опитування тільки дві
людини мали професійну освіту 18 касирів
мали вищу освіту 18 касирів тобто людина
яку максимум там потрібно там 2-3 тижні
там гарно навчати щоб вона вміла
працювати на касі ця людина від- відбула
декілька років навчальному ВУЗі Тобто
вона витратила свої роки життя вона
витратила чи то власні кошти чи то
батьків чи то державні кошти і потім
вона ще мало того моральний клімат вона
не зреалізувались з іншої сторони якщо
ми дійсно все ж таки там хай не за
сьогодні там не за рік не за два за
п'ять за сім років найближчим змінимо у
уяву суспільства про те що
професіональна освіта це не чим не гірше
а можливо навіть і краще в більшості
випадків ніж вища освіта от на ці ми
маємо працювати Чому Тому що наприклад
та сама Європа
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30
насправді дуже волелюдно не тільки на
нашій сцені під час обговорення не
тільки безпосередньо бачите на наших
прес-конференціях Але і в холі в
кулуарах де розміщена наша експозони
причому справді вона насичена багатьма
багатьма локаціями Зараз ми біля великої
зони Національної академії наук України
але зупинимося на українських розробках
зокрема це Інститут електрозварювання
легендарний імені Патона національна
Академії Наук України і ми поговоримо
про оцею апарат прошу показати який
називається Патон мед А вас попрошу
розповісти Більше про нього це апарат
створений в інституті
для
заміни
в хірургії таких
в операціях для заміни
ігулок ні так от давайте Я перейду на
русский кажіть
для
производства операции без использования
ниток иголок и всё короче сварювання
обеспечивают герметичность И качество
соединения такое которые недоступно при
других при других методах просто це і
судини і тканини і органи
герметичні
наприклад
ті хірурги які це апаратами цими
пользуються а їх уже декілька сотень
робить по Україні вони не Скільки ж
років тобто він уже
практично застосовується так а от нам
цікаво Бо можливо не всі занурені наші
глядачі форуму перед тим як 10 років
тому він уже почав
використовуватись безпосере практичній
медицині скільки потрібно було вам
науковцям і безпосередньо самим хірургам
провести час досліджень експериментів
перед тим як воно запускається уже
безпосередньо щоб уже це можна було
безпечно використовувати для людини Ну
ви знаєте почалось це десь 2000 році
тут 10 років було
випробувань Випробування різні апарати
ми робили але ці апарати ще не були
досконалі і тільки через 10 років Ми
вийшли на досконале на той рівень який
зараз яка точність може бути таких
операцій на що спрямовано тому що
Наскільки я розумію подібні приблизні
так якісь можливо розробки теж Вони
завжди стосувалися безпосередньо того
чому самому руках хірурга що важко
зробити тобто наскільки це може бути
якісь такі точні мікро екологічні
операції Давайте так от бачите режими є
тут різання коагуляція ручне зведення
автоматичне звернення при автоматичному
зварюванні кваліфікації хірурга вже
немає великого значення якщо він
перекриває наприклад судину
він перерізає судину треба її зразу ж
перекрити щоб кровотечі не було то в
автоматичному режимі
гарантується що буде перекриття таке що
забезпечує безкровну операцію а
і ми на наших
коли проводили експерименти то бачили що
на наших комах скажіть До речі мені
цікаво на наших на співробітниках можна
порося так багато бо на людях не можна в
нас є своя операційна даже в інституті і
ми це робиться щоб зараз нас зо
Захисники це що просто лікували тварин
зараз одразу
мудра акція Я у вас запитував щодо того
що цікаво наскільки точність тому що у
нас же судини теж різні може воно є
Великого діаметру тобто настільки
автоматичний автоматичний режим що
значить автоматичний режим хірург
натиснув на педаль і там іде перше
апарат підготує судину до зварювання
ідуть імпульси потім апарат визначає яка
це судина сам без без хірурга яка судина
який об'єм цієї судини потім заварює там
є залежність
програмне забезпечення забезпечення
різні залежності все з аварії
і
після цього перевіряє правильно заварив
Неправильно заварив стабілізує тканину і
гарантує Що наприклад от судина скільки
її витримує Ну у людини 240 мм Да Ну я
не знаю
давлением 240 да
тиск
в судини ну це це вже дуже велике а то
що ми зварюємо буває витримує 800 і 800
000 Да То есть гарантовано якісне
зварювання Ми зупинилися на питаннях
судини Я бачив так що попереднього
презентацію що ти не тільки стосується
судин це тканин те що ми
розширюємо його можливості і Наприклад
тут єсть клініка Філатова в Одессе де
привариться сітчатка ока а це взагалі
мікроскопічні такі мікроскопічні при
цьому цим апаратом ми з вами ще
продовжимо обов'язково ці наукові
відкриття для наших глядачів форум
Україна 30 І що повернулася до експозони
А зараз мусимо повертатися на основну
сцену і там буде дуже цікаво
бачимо які є поміж тими Які взагалі на
попиті завжди це управлінські навички це
всі навички які пов'язані із
когнітивними звичками не буду говорити
софтовими більше зумів працювати з
інформацією
Це дуже цікаво я так моя припущення може
бути що якщо ви в рівні ви вимірювали
рівень тривожності То напевно Потім були
якісь
освітні програми з емоційного інтелекту
ще не було
припущення інтелект також на попиті але
ми його інкорпоруємо у програми
пов'язані із управлінськими навичками
підвищуємо рівень розуміння що це І як
це саме в таких програмах ще одне
питання яке потім я переадресую всім
учасникам як вимірюєте
рівень ефективності своєї роботи тому що
Ну ми коли ми спілкуємось ось
підприємцями Я завжди йому там яка вас
вижечка яка у вас доляринкою там дикі
прости є метрики з якими можна сказати
що компанія успішна або неуспішна як в
бізнес-школу на це питання до всіх
учасників які метрики використовувати
щоб оцінювати
поміж основними дискусіями і сесіями
воно заплановані і в презентації Я
запрошую зараз на сцену заступницю
міністра із питань тимчасово окупованих
територій України Інну Драганчук та
голову під комітету із питань освіти
впродовж життя та позашкільної освіти
комітету Верховної Ради України з питань
освіти науки та інновації Романа грищука
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні глядачі Шановні
телеглядачі шановні
шановні присутні в цьому залі Ми
сьогодні хочемо поговорити про непросту
тему освіту для дітей з окупованих
територій що робить держава які є
виклики які є проблеми як ми всі знаємо
спочатку окупації Криму та війни на
Донбасі Міністерство освіти науки
України разом з громадським суспільством
створило освітні центри крим-україна
Донбас України через які діти з
окупованих територій могли вступати до
закладів вищої освіти
професійно-технічної освіти без
складання зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання щороку кількість дітей які
скористалися цією можливістю
збільшується проте є багато проблем і
викликів з яким ми зіштовхуємося
саме тому Минулого року завдяки
законодавчі ініціативи президента
України Володимира Зеленського вперше
було розширено перелік закладів вищої
освіти до яких можуть вступати діти з
окупованих територій з минулого року
діти з окупованого Криму І окупованих
частин Донецької Луганської області
можуть вступати в будь-які заклади вищої
освіти в Україні проте з якими
проблемами стикається молодь пані Інна
хотів би дати вам слово сказати
Доброго дня шановні колеги
напевне Варто сказати про те що ми не до
кінця усвідомлюємо перебуваючи в Києві
або на будь-які іншій частині вільне
України Про те що відбувається тимчасово
окупованих територіях більшість новин
які ми отримуємо вони є достатньо
контроверсійною з точки зору висвітлення
і в принципі той конфлікт який штучно
намагаються деякі Скажімо так не до
кінця свідомі напевно громадяни України
створити це відображено насправді
сьогоднішня країни я можу вам сказати
безумовно будучи само одинчанкою яка
приїхала давно в Київ мова що я
приїжджала дуже готовою будучи найкраще
напевно студенткою в майбутньому в
своєму університеті тому мені зараз дуже
легко вам адвокатувати і пояснювати чому
важливо створювати умови для того щоб
умовити інтегрувалась тимчасово
окупованих територій саме шляхом їх
освіти тому що освіта це просто найкраще
метотре інтеграції молоді
наведення зараз цитати які на залишать
будь-кого з вас байдужими це цитати
звичайних студентів які приїхали
Минулого року здобувачами вищої освіти в
Україну для мене Кожна з цих Тез вона є
абсолютно безцінною тому що ви розумієте
це не декларації політиків це не
будь-які високі матерії про які ми
можемо з вами читати або здогадуватись
це цитати живих дітей які пояснюють що
для них здобування освіти в Україні
найдорожча яка тут є це звичайна фраза
про те що тут вільніше бо ми з вами не
розуміємо що таке опинитися в окупації
що таке залежати від батьків які
проживають на тимчасово окупованих
територіях і фактично можливо не завжди
розділяють цінності нових українців
нової генерації українців які зараз
виростають під час війни а безумовно
одне з найбільших проблем це є проблема
проживання дітей проблема дістатись до
вільної України тому що це може
коштувати до 7 тисяч гривень і ви також
маєте зважати комунікуючи з вашими
колегами про те наскільки цінна ця
освіта для дітей які задоволення їдуть
навчатися на вільну Україну
основні проблеми які ми бачимо на
сьогодні є це безпосередньо нестача
інформації тому що будь-яка ініціатива
яка створюється будь-яка умова зі
сторони нашої держави яка
запроваджується для молоді вона Скажімо
так блокується тому що це не вигідно
пояснювати що море Тут чекають безумовно
те що ми можемо боротися безкінечно і на
жаль поки що не може сказати що
максимально успішна це ворожа Пропаганда
ми говоримо тільки про пропаганду
окупаційної влади Звичайно це
пропагандистська російська махіна з якої
Скажімо так нам досить важко протистояти
ми розуміємо чому да І це все базується
безпосередньо на тимчасово окупованих
територій і наші діти використовуються
проти нас можна сказати якась тривала
зброя тому що фактично їх використовують
таким чином щоб штучно нав'язувати
конфлікт якого насправді не існує
розуміння сприйняття цих дітей на
вільній території України
Значить основна проблема які ми бачимо
які цілі ми для себе ми розуміємо
запроваджуючи цю програму завдяки
ініціативам про які зараз розповів пан
Роман розповів детальніше це
безпосередньо саме безпечна інтеграція
Молодість тимчасово окупованих територій
це створення абсолютних сприятливих умов
для того щоб цей діалог відбувся тому що
будемо відвертими дуже мало молодих
людей які проживають на вільній Україні
до кінця усвідомлюють наші реалії і
виходить що нас штучна прірва яка існує
між дітьми які вже не до кінця розуміють
наше сьогоденну історію і дітьми які в
цій історії ростуть вигадай виховань
виховання покоління агентів змін моїм
колегам я пояснюю що наші майбутні
пенсії будуть залежати від того
наскільки Ми сьогодні зможемо
проінвестувати в освіту Повірте це дуже
переконно дуже багатьох колег поставити
з розумінням що саме ці діти в
майбутньому платитиме нам пенсії саме
Від них залежатиме на наш побут це
найкраще надієвіший метод для того щоб
донести і переконати наскільки Для нас
це важливо формування позитивного
ставлення саме імідже молоді з тимчасово
окупованих територій Я думаю що
більшість з вас одна скалахнула історія
декілька днів тому коли дитина дівчина
прийшла з тимчасово окупованою
територією Через заміноване поле ви
розумієте що таких випадків значно
більше просто у нас не прийнята їх
висвітлювати і моя задача разом з
колегами бути основним адвокатом і
пояснювати що те що штучне надлом який
існує сьогодні в суспільстві з точки
зору прийняття цієї молоді це зовсім
абсолютно неправдоподібна історія коли
спілкуюсь під час своїх візитів можна
сказати додому донеччину звичайно там
під час обіймів семи хлопцями які
навчаються в горлівському переміщеному
університеті це звичайні неймовірно
мотивовані найкращі випускники звичайно
закладів середньої освіти та тимчасове
окуповані території Проте вони вже
переконали наскільки вони є українцями і
це не може бути Скажімо так з вимору
якоїсь штучної патріотичності це дійсно
не просто про наміри це їх про їх
конкретні дії
Тут напевно пане Роман я би хотіла щоб
ви розказали про здобутки як такі
долучені ви я хочу залишити думкою
компанії нас сказала У нас іде битва
битва за Уми і Битва за Душі за Душі
наших громадян які знаходяться на
окупованій території за душу наших дітей
які випускаючись з закладу
здобуваючи освіту в школах Вони думають
куди їм їхати їм їхати в Україну Про яку
їм розказують що там жахливо чим їхати в
Росію чи залишатися на окупованих
територіях ми бачимо статистику кожного
року потрішки потрішки зростає та
кількість дітей які через Крим Україна
Донбас Україна їдуть в Україну але ми
маємо розуміти що проблем стає все
більше що Зараз будуть випускатися зі
шкіл окупованих діти які Україну
пам'ятають тільки з початкової школи і з
кожним роком це розрив буде ставати все
більше і більше Через декілька років
взагалі діти будуть випускатися з
окупованих територій які навчалися
тільки там які слухали тільки російську
пропаганду тому бачу ці цифри
була висунута законодавчення ініціатива
про яку я вже розказав це доступ до всіх
закладів вищої освіти більше того
завдяки президенту України народним
депутатом була закладена можливість
проведення підготовчих курсів зі
стипендіальним забезпеченням та
проживанням для випускників з окупованих
територій І от саме про це я хотів би
розказати трішечки детально і пояснити
цього року ми разом з вами будемо
пілотувати цю історію ми спробуємо крім
просто надання можливості навчатися в
закладі освіти надамо дітям можливість
реінтегруватися кожен випускник цього
року який закінчив школу в Криму чи
окупованому Донецьку та Луганську може
приїхати в Україну через освітній центр
unintelligible країна Донбасу України
обрати будь-який заклад вищу освіти і за
літні місяці пройти підготовку до
навчання підготовка зі стипендіальним
забезпеченням підготовку з проживанням
тому що як сказала пані Інна величезна
проблема - це повернення на окуповану
територію правило одного виїзду тобто
дитина яка приїхала подала документи
освітні центр крим-україна Донбасу
України відновила українські сертифікат
про повну загальну середню освіту склала
екзамени вона не може повернутися тому
ми завдяки цим підготовчим курсам
надаємо їм можливість проживати в
університеті
було обрано 23 заклади вищої освіти
України які проявили інтерес який
захотіли організувати прийняти участь у
цьому пілотному проекті для того щоб для
того щоб
інтегрувати дітей для того щоб
підтягнути їх знання української мови
історію України для того щоб вони з
першого вересня почувалися сильніше і
змогли виходити в навчання на рівні з
усіма пані і на Розкажіть що це будуть
за університети
знову ж таки я буду зараз каменікувати
безпосередньо як дитина з Донеччини яка
свого часу приїхала на Київщину моя мама
була директором великої школи в Донецьку
і на момент коли я приїжджали в Київ а в
мене Звичайно вже була Золота медаль в
іншій школі тому ще була відміна це дуже
мотивована мріяла вчитись в Києві але
фактично українська мова для мене яке
для більшості дітей сходить Це була
пасивна мова зараз дуже важливий момент
мені пояснити мої діти говорять виключно
українською мовою це сталось давно вони
вже дуже дорослі але щоб ви розуміли
коли ми приїжджали додому до батьків
вони звичайно говорили зі всіма
українською мовою від продавців які
продавали якісь кульки закінчуючи в
магазинах і будь-який дорослий
громадянин Донеччини завжди спілкувався
українською мовою це при знов ж таки про
момент коли пан Роман зараз пояснив про
те що можна адаптувати і покращити
українську мову Повірте Це питання часу
це не може бути виміром того коли ми
говоримо про академічну освіту і різницю
діток які будуть приїжджати з тимчасово
окупованих територій Чи це може бути
основним моментом Повірте ні мотивація і
ми скажемо так вона не може бути
сумнівним значить повертаючись до нашого
вибору університеті про яке зараз вам
розповім звичайно ми хотіли щоб
університети на базі яких буде
реалізована ініціатива президента щоб це
були найбільш мотивовані університети
які готові і хочуть приймати працювати з
дітками з тимчасово окупованих територій
Відповідно ми скажемо так провели дуже
непросту комунікаційну роботу з нашим З
нашими з вашими колегами з університетів
і фактично можна сказати в особистому
контакті намагалось роз'яснити чому це
важливо саме на базі цих університетів
запроваджувати ці програми Отже всі
університети отримали запрошення проте
тільки якщо не помиляюсь 33 університети
відповідали скажімо відгукнулася наша
ініціативу з них були вибрана 23 вищі
навчальні заклади географії цих
університетів ви зараз бачите це від
Маріуполя і бахмута до Львова Минулого
року до Львівської політехніки вступила
22 вступника з тимчасово окупованої
території з Криму це не всього 22
вступника Уявіть собі дітей які йдуть
навчатися у Київської політехніку з
Криму потрібно щось доводити Ні це цілих
22 громадянина України які маючи
можливість навчатися в університетах
Російської Федерації обирають для себе
львівщину це дуже важливо Отже зараз
університет перелік ви бачите перед
собою Скажімо так географію ви вже
побачили для нас найбільшим досягненням
є ще серед цих університетів які
являються базовими по навчанню молоді з
тимчасово окупованих територій наприклад
приміщена ні так само цього року бере
участь національний університет імені
Тараса Шевченка Ми дуже тішимося що нас
бере Київська політехніка Львівський
університет тобто є графік ну дуже-дуже
широка податкова університет в Ірпені
діти можуть обрати будь-які університети
на базі якого вони будуть отримувати
навчання у вигляді цих підготовчих
курсів зі стипендіальним забезпеченням
при тому вони не обмежені до вступу в
будь-який університет Які дотепер є
відкритим для їх прийоми і подальшого
навчання Ну скажімо Так це найважливіше
з оптимістично того що ми маємо
транслювати постійно що ми не маємо їх
обмежувати у виборі проте те що ми
пропонуємо цього року саме у вигляді
пілотного навчання на підготовчий курсах
це є безумовною перевагою для того щоб
вони швидше адаптувалися і інтегрувалися
вже в суспільстві в якому фактично З 1
вересня вони стануть повноцінними
студентами Роман я щиро вдячний тим
університетам закладом вищої освіти які
погодилися дійсно буде компенсація від
держави за це навчання дійсно за
проживання в гуртожитках буде сплаче
повна вартість для цих університетів
Тобто ми коли захищали бюджет ми хотіли
щоб закладом вищої освіти було вигідно
навчати цих дітей щоб закладам вищої
освіти було вигідно проводити у себе ж
курси для того щоб простіше комунікувати
так до нас вже і поступаєте Да зараз
дітки можуть обрати будь-які заклад
вищої освіти А курси проходити або в
тому місці в якому їх знаходиться їх
заклад вищої освіти ну або в
будь-якому із перелічених 23
сьогоднішнього дня по 20 червня починає
можна подавати документи з 29 червня вже
починається підготовчі курси по
університетах із 29 червня коли дитина
приїжджає подавати документи вона вже
може одразу поселитися в тому закладі
вищої освіти в якому буде проходити
проходити ті підготовчі курси в кінці
підготовчі курсів складається в
підсумковий іспит з кожної з навчальних
академічних дисциплін які будуть там
обов'язково українська мова історія
України отримання сертифікату по
завершенню підготовчих курсів І
найважливіше для нас першого вересня
випускник курсів дитина яка за клопотує
два поступала в український заклад вищої
освіти стає абсолютно рівною з усіма
іншими жодної позитивної дискримінації І
хотілося щоб негативної не було з 1
вересня Це звичайний український студент
якого ми всі разом з вами Да з
представниками закладів вищої освіти
маємо навчити і дати йому якісну освіту
Ми дуже сподіваємося що завдяки цим
підготовчим курсам дітям буде простіше
входити в непростий навчальний процес
руйнувати міфи які їм насаджувалися
ну і да переваги для молоді що це дає
можливість інтегруватись за місцем
проживання дати уже три місяці чи два
місяці живеш в місті в якому ти будеш
навчатися тобі буде простіше З 1 вересня
буде проводитися в закладах вищої освіти
Ти можеш обрати спеціальність яку ти
йдеш і Цей заклад вище освіти або те які
готують за цією спеціальністю стипендія
у розмірі двох прожиткових мінімумів
тобто
два місяці дитина з окупованих територій
яка проходить ці підготовчі курси
завдяки законопроекту президента буде
отримувати отримувати ці кошти Ну і
краще заклади вищої освіти я щиро
вдячний Київському політехнічному
інституту
книгу імені Шевченка також всім
університетом які погодилися на
підготовчі курси
Ну і я не знаю найосновніший меседж який
ми хотіли б е-е донести да це цілі які
ми ставимо це хотілося б щоб від 500 до
750 дітей пройшли ці підготовчі курси Це
надзвичайно велика е-е цифра ми
розуміємо тому що зараз йде величезний
опір на окупованих територіях з приводу
навчання дітей в Україні Проте ми собі
ставимо ці амбітні цілі Ну і
найосновніше те що ми хотіли б попросити
кожного з вас кожного хто зараз
присутній в залі чи кожного хто дивиться
цю відеотрансляцію
Ми Точно знаємо що Які би ми не
намагались декларативні стейтменти
робити для Скажімо так для наших
основних кінцевих реципієнтів молодих
людей Вони закінчаться рівно там де
починається реальність реальність
починається там коли наші діти які вже
отримують тут здобувають вищу освіту
дзвонять додому і говорять що
відбувається насправді тобто найкраще
комунікація це виключно наша комунікація
з рідними з друзями з друзями з друзів
Відповідно ми будемо дуже просити
кожного з вас щоб ви максимально могли
використати всі ваші можливі контакти
робочі особисті для того щоб доносити цю
інформацію тому що скільки ви мене
використовували можливі телеграм-канали
скільки б ви мене разів не звертались до
діток Ну за всіма можливими методами
комунікації все одно найсильнішою
комунікація являється комунікація правди
правда правда є В тому що ми їх чекаємо
правда я в тому що ці діти для нас є Ну
скажімо так для мене особисто є
повноцінною Надією в тому що це новітня
історія України тому що реінтеграція
буде тривати дуже довго і ми дуже
насправді часто використовуємо цей
термін напевно від розмов на кухні
закінчується політичними трибунами але
дуже мало людей усвідомлять що це таке і
безпосередньо
кого ми зараз виборюємо для кого Ми
створюємо ці умови вони і будуть
втіленням тієї реінтеграції про яку ми
так багато всі говоримо і мало до кінця
розуміємо напевно наскільки це буде
непростий процес для нашої історії тому
кожного з вас Запрошуємо до цієї Битви
за Уми душі через освіту
Подзвоніть знайомим з окупованим
території скажіть їм що їхніх дітей тут
чекають в будь-якому закладі вищого
освіти скажіть їм що на цих діток
чекають підготовчі реінтеграційні курси
зі степандіальним забезпеченням і з
проживанням і скажіть якщо моїх любимо
моїх чекаємо дякуємо
Дякуємо за презентацію і актуальну
важливу інформацію зокрема для наших
випускників і майбутніх абітурієнтів із
тимчасово окупованих територій зовсім
скоро Ми продовжимо велике обговорення
дискусії сесії на цій основні залі на
сцені форуму України 30
більшість учнів українських шкіл торік
перейшли на дистанційне навчання через
пандемію ковід-19 за підтримки
Міністерства освіти і науки та
Міністерства цифрової трансформації
запрацювало платформа всеукраїнська
школа онлайн вона розрахована на учні у
5-11 класів тепер на цій платформі понад
півтори тисячі уроків і понад 167 тисяч
користувачів 125 тисяч учнів 34 тисячі
вчителів і більше ніж
8000 слухачів
право дітей з інвалідністю на здобуття
якісної освіти державний пріоритет
поточного навчального року в інклюзивних
класах українських шкіл навчається
більше ніж 25 тисяч учнів це майже в 10
разів більше ніж 5 років тому 43% шкіл
мають інклюзивні класи згідно з над
стратегією розвитку інклюзивної освіти
яку розробило міноосвіти і науки за 10
років усі заклади освіти мають
відповідати принципам безбар'єрності
щотижня це місце ставатиме майданчиком
для головних тем України серія із 30
масштабних щотижневих Воронів України до
річниці державної Незалежності
це великий діалог за участі влади
громадськості міжнародних партнерів
українських експертів децентралізація в
дії комп'ютер не бере хабаря форум - Це
пошук стратегій і тактий величезний
поштовх економіки і будівництво в
Україні поява стратегії інформаційної
безпеки підвищення якості ефективності
чинного законодавства Україна відкрито
говорить і шукає рішення збирає найкращі
світовий досвід економічні зв'язки між
Україною та Литвою всі мають визнавати
міжнародну визнані кордони Європейський
союз на боці України як і був завжди під
час форуму Влада спілкується з
журналістами
представники медіа беруть коментарі у
спікерів також відбуваються спеціальні
сесії форуму
а буквально доторкнутися до теми можна в
експозоній формі
ті форми може дати вам розуміння
багатьох процесів корисної інформації та
відповіді на дуже важливі хвилюючі
запитання
форум Україна 30 це відкрита і факова
розмова на найважливіші теми в житті
країни що є опорами нашої Незалежності
це теж форум Україна 30 освіта і наука
Тільки наша експозона яка у центральному
Холі і ми зараз для ну Великого
комплексу стендів Національної академії
наук України і це міжнародне наукового
навчальний центр інформаційних
технологій та систем і дуже важливий
прилад про який
розкаже це
реабілітаційний апарат для якраз
відновлення здоров'я після інсульту
розкажіть більше про цей винахід і де
він зараз застосовується наскільки
широко
реабілітолог самопо себе название
говорят о том что предназначенная его
функциональное назначение
реабилитировать а именно реабилитировать
двигательные функции после тяжелеших
заболеваний центральной периферической
нервной системы у взрослых и детей таких
например социально значимых заболеваний
как инсульт или детский церебральный
паралич апарат этот
от идеи до реальногоплощения прошёл
довольно длительный путь не випробування
і он имел Испытание Клинические
испытания он разрешён к серийному
производству к использованию в
медицинской практике и в настоящее время
он используется в 17-клиниках и курортах
Украины доказал свою
результативность восстано
более чем на двадцати одной тисячі
пациентов с различными нозологией
повторяю центральный периферической
нервной системы особенно успешного
неспользуется в городе Киеве вдвох
реабилизационных центрах один из них
реабилитационный центр это клиника э-э
державна науково неприбуткова
підприємства Київська міська клінічна
лікарня номер три
реабилизационный центр зал отделением
э-э и друга лікарня друга лікарня это
центр инновационных медицинских
технологий принадлежащие академии наук
Украины Я дякую ми власне зацікавили
нашу аудиторію дуже важливо знати що
дуже багато наших інститутів і
підрозділів центрів в системі
Національної академії наук України
працюють
для реального застосування і у сфері
виробництва і економіки і медицини - це
дуже важливо Дякую вам а ми мусимо далі
повертатися до основної сцени де зовсім
скоро розпочнеться наступна дискусія
знання - це скарб а вміння вчитись ключ
до нього українська освіта змінюється
вона стає гнучкішою і сучаснішою
цифровою і безбар'єрними наука все
більше цікавить молодь розробки і
винаходи перетворюються на стартапи а
держава підтримує і мотивує
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 освіта і
наука
більшість учнів українських шкіл торік
перейшли на дистанційне навчання через
пандемію ковід-19 за підтримки
Міністерства освіти і науки та
Міністерства цифрової трансформації
запрацювала платформа всеукраїнська
школа онлайн вона розрахована на учні у
п'ятих 11-х класів тепер на цій
платформі понад півтори тисячі уроків і
понад 167 тисяч користувачів 125 тисяч
учнів 34 тисячі вчителів і більше ніж
8000 слухачів
це форум Україна 30 освіта і наука і
далі наступне обговорення сесія дискусія
про власну освітню траєкторію я передаю
мікрофон одразу цього обговорення це у
студії онлайн освіти Едера Ілля Філіпов
бажаю вам змістовних обговорень Дякую
Вітаю всіх учасників мені надзвичайно
подобається тема яку ми зараз будемо
обговорювати тому що всі напевно
спостерігають як швидко змінюється світ
як швидко змінюється канали сприйняття
як швидко змінюється те як поглинають
інформацію сучасні студенти молодь і
тому подібне
наразі реформувати освіту моє глибоке
переконання потрібно весь час та
неперервно навіть ті продукти які ми там
робили навіть нашою студію там три чи
чотири роки тому зараз ми перероблюємо
тому що розуміємо що вже той самий
старшокласник змінився і мені
дуже велика честь презентувати всіх
учасників нашої панельної дискусії тому
що кожен із них докладає певних зусиль
для того щоб траєкторію навчання справді
була власною індивідуальна у кожної
людини
тому представляю вам хто у нас учасники
по-перше цей Ігор гербарук заступник
міністра освіти і науки України
Роман тичківський керівник Української
Академії лідерства
Альона Тимошенко керівниця першої
української кіношколи Ukrainian film
school
та Світлана Гриценко директорка освітніх
програм фонду Віктора Пінчука
А ще до нас під’єднається онлайн Василь
Дяків педагог переможець національної
премії Global teacher Price Ukraine 2020
Дякую У кожного з учасників є
є вода
[сміх]
у кожного з учасників є невеличке слово
з їхньою власною презентацією а потім ми
з радістю обговоримо із вами певні
Питання якщо у вас такі виникнуть і один
з одним сподіваюсь також і перше слово
давайте щоб не було когнітивного
дисонансу я також надам Ігорю і так і
будемо рухатися по черзі дякую
Всім доброго дня Ну як категорично проти
слова по-перше Ігор грабарук заступник
Міністра я от колега взагалі пропонував
мене залишити десь на на кінець для того
щоб спочатку могли колеги виступити а
вже потім десь А якщо з'явиться на цьому
екрані моя презентація за е-е якщо
Хлопці запустять бо тут бачу а там ні А
я хочу навіть трошки змінити свій виступ
який я планував Чому тому що насправді
От вчора і президент прем'єр-міністр
Міністр освіти а вони говорили більше
міряє про власний приклад досягнення
певних речей з колегами тільки що на
прес-конференції такий невеличкий
імпровізованій ми говорили більшій мірі
про власний досвід саме тому я сьогодні
хотів з вами поговорити про
професійно-технічну освіту і я про це
поговорив але знаєте Спершу я зроблю
трошки інакше Давайте я вам з вашого
дозволу розумію що хлопця операторам
Союзу зараз картинку А я хочу розуміти
що мікрофонів немає але хочу задати
питання Скажіть будь ласка давайте так
проголосуємо В кого є діти В мене точно
є Да класно А в кого є діти які
закінчили школу в мене чи ні так добре а
тепер Давайте я вам задам запитання дуже
провокативне
перше питання Скажіть будь ласка хто з
вас як з батьків вплинув на отримання
тої чи іншої освіти своїми дітьми тільки
чесно
ну декілька чесних людей є да насправді
А хто взагалі не впливав от ви береш що
хочеш
ще дивніша ситуація я чисть по-перше
більше дітей їй батьків цьому залі
насправді Це абсолютно нормально Коли як
казали мої студенти кажу першого світу
нам дають батьки другу ми вибираємо самі
знову ж таки я вже казав просто
особистий приклад в мене так само точно
так само колеги які знаходяться в залі є
їх бачив Всім привіт А вони знають про
те що в мене перша освіта дуже музична
музична школа музичне училище
консерваторія по класу скрипки сім років
роботи в камерному оркестрі потім
академії держ управління при
президентові України робота в бізнесі
робота на Державній Службі і на
сьогоднішній день допрацювався до
заступника міністра насправді це не
головне абсолютно головне про те що ми
хочемо що я хочу про що я хочу говорити
про що хочу сказати ми маємо змінити
певну усталену парадигму Моя дитина має
мати вищу освіту для чого кому це
потрібно вам чи дитині от задавайтесь
будь ласка завжди цим питанням а
ситуація в тому що 180% випускників шкіл
чомусь прагнуть піти
вищі навчальний заклад Ми з колегами
тільки що говорили я при наводив приклад
колекції Львова своїх з якого Тільки
повернувся зробили невеличкий
невеличке дослідження прям в торговому
залі одної великої роздрібної мережі
коли з 20 касирів коли їх опитали де
вони вчились тільки дві людини Два
касира сказали що вони мають професійно
технічно освіту 18 Як ви думаєте Яку
мають освіту вищу Скажіть будь ласка
держава витратила кошти чи батьки на них
витратила вони витратили 5 років свого
життя на це витратили Скажіть будь ласка
який в людей моральний клімат
внутрішній що я 5 років навчався і я
працюю ким касиром в супермаркеті тобто
абсолютно нормально Це дуже шанована
професія я сам як людина яка вийшла з
ретейлу дуже довго там працював в серії
роздрібної торгівлі я чітко знаю що це
дуже шанована Професія це професія яка
насправді робить е-е любому ретил в
бізнес але насправді Я вважаю що держава
і суспільство мають змінити ті певні
парадигми і все ж таки звернути в
більшій мірі на європейській досвід на
європейські гори досвід про те що 40 50
до 70% випускників шкіл Куди йдуть в
сферу професійної освіти відповідно на
сьогоднішній день в Україні працює 708
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
більше там практично 240 000 слухачів є
І от буквально там з 16-го року в якійсь
частині особливо два останніх роки
ситуація з сфери професійної освіти
бачите навіть відходжу від
словосполучення професійно-технічні вона
почала мінятися вона почала мінятися
Чому Тому що на рівні держави на рівні
політичних
політичних компетенцій політичних
комунікацій почалось змінювати
відношення до професійної освіти тому що
насправді все ж таки ми маємо говорити
про те що і президентом і
прем'єр-міністром велика кількість уваги
звернена на а саме постійну освіту
навіть прем'єр-міністр вчора знаходячись
на цьому місці сказав що дуальну освіту
потрібно впроваджувати не тільки в
професійній освіті але все ж таки
переводити і вищу освіту тому відповідно
ці всі напрямки мають бути поєднані
знову ж таки особисто увага а-а
президента України указ президента
України Рада поправтехам яка створена
яка найближчим часом буде збиратися
велика конференція яка відбудеться Я вже
анонсую на початку липня у Львові це все
доводить про те що насправді в
суспільстві і на рівні держави
відношення до професійної освіти почало
змінюватись знову ж таки завдячуючи
роботі з депутатами з профільним
комітетом ми на сьогоднішній день
працюємо над законопроектом про
професійно про професійну освіту там
буде закладено дуже багато гарних речей
буде закладений і автономія вузів і
можливість отримання другої професійної
освіти безкоштовно Тобто там Буде багато
різноманітних сентенцій Ну але кажуть
зробимо презентуємо побачити оціните і
буде можливість знову ж таки вам всім як
суспільство висловитись знову ж таки
якщо говорити дійсно продуальну освіту Я
взагалі вважаю що
дуальна освіта - це дійсно
майбутнє яке вже діє Сьогодні знову ж
таки в тій концепції яку вчора міністр
презентував по президентському
університеті саме принцип дуальної
освіти 30х70 закладений як основний Але
знову ж таки достатньо часто ми
ми розуміємо однієї дуже простої речі що
насправді коли ми говоримо про тих 30
всі чимось сприймаються якщо теорія
чиста теорія нічого більше Насправді Я
пропоную вам як викладачам університетів
суспільства задуматись трошки на іншому
що в цих 30 потрібно виносити дві
ключові речі перше - це робота з певною
проблематикою чому ми всі боїмося
проблем ми вирішуємо якісь питання але
боїмося проблеми і знову ж таки коли ти
не боїшся проблеми розумієш як з нею
працювати потрібно дати що студенту
слухачу інструментарій оцього 30% - це
робота з проблемою і робота з
інструментами а вже 70%. це від
лабораторії які там в надзвичайних
закладах до реального виробництва коли
ти працюєш разом з досвідченим майстром
ось це все має бути відповідно Це ті
показники які є подолання освітні на
сьогоднішній день буде рухатись далі
знову ж таки друга тема це про те що
казав вчора міністр навчально-практичні
центри на сьогоднішній день практично
вже там 200 центнерів існує і вони на
сьогоднішній день я покажу зараз які
вони є на сьогоднішній день вони дійсно
є тими магнітами які перевертають
ситуацію до професійної освіти саме вони
на сьогоднішній день а допомагають
звернути увагу на професійну освіту це і
коштом держави відбувається кожного року
збільшується Ця сума яка виділяється це
коштом місцевих органів влади це коштом
бізнес-компанії тобто реально сектор
економіки вони створюються і вони на
сьогоднішній день І дійсно ну
просто можливо погано видно
здолбунівське вище професійне училище
залізничного транспорту ось воно
виглядає Ось так далі Львівський
професійний коледж ресторанного
господарства Повірте заїдете до Ганни
Федорівни Волощак Львів вона всіх прийме
казала якщо я буду її рекламувати тому
відповідно Заїжджайте до неї побачите що
це відбувається це не просто ресторан це
там де
проходять практику слухачі освіти в
цьому колезі далі навчальний ресторан
коледж Ось таким от чином це виглядає це
коледж це всього-на-всього коледжу але
знаєте Я в цих випадках завжди кажу дуже
просто
керівники навчальних закладів як правило
діляться на дві ключі від категорії ті
які завжди плачуть про те що в них немає
грошей дайте гроші і ми щось там зробимо
і ті які в тій самій ситуації
знаходяться але роблять працюють і
досягають результату тому саме от на це
мій ми звертаємо ну найбільшу увагу
знову ж таки Червоноградський
професійний гірничо-будівельний ліцей
так працює знову ж Михайлівський вище
професійне училище
Львівське вище професійне училище
технології та сервісу
Кременчук взагалі От так як працює
Кременчук так як їх спеціалістів вони на
сьогоднішній день випускають Це просто
унікальне саме тому Ну це моя кохана
Рівне Ти теж відзначається певними
речами відповідно коли є ми маємо разом
з вами змінити відношення до професійної
освіти тому що саме робочими руками
будується країна саме цим шляхом Якщо ми
будемо йти Ми змінимо країну і Ми
змінимо її на краще дякую всім за увагу
дуже надихаючий виступ дуже приємно було
побачити такі сучасні профтех освітні
заклади і я сподіваюся що справді у вас
великий репутаційний виклик насправді
щоб довести що така освіта у нас може
бути гарною і мені здається що Ось такі
ілюстрації це також дуже гарна промоція
реклама і так далі Я також згоден що не
кожному потрібно вища освіта у нас в
Україні і потрібно з цим щось робити щоб
люди розуміли Яка у них є альтернатива
відповідно передаю слово далі роману
тичківському керівнику Української
Академії лідерства який також в принципі
свій проект присвячує тому щоб людина ви
мене поправите Роман якщо я щось скажу
не так але мені здається що одна з цілей
проекту щоб людина справді змогла
зробити більшу усвідомлений вибір у
своєму житті молода людина і е-е цього
Мені здається вкрайном не вистачало у
нашій формальні території ти народився
пішов в садок в школу університет потім
думають що робити зі своїм життям і
слава Богу це потрішки змінюється Роман
вам слово Дуже дякую
мені в якійсь мірі легко продовжити
перейнявши естафету після пана Ігоря як
батька як
офіційна особа яка сьогодні є Серед
лідерів нашого
профільного відомства адже я говоритиму
про свободу вибору молодої людини коли
вас не відбувається перехід від
середньої освіти до вже вимір дорослого
життя яка зазвичай в більшості випадків
мабуть в більшості
серед більшості з тих хто тут ці
аудиторії почалося власне здобуття вищої
освіти і власне для нас тих хто сьогодні
творить Українську академію лідерства
надзвичай дуже важливим є
продемонструвати суспільство що молодь
наша з вами молодь - це той шалений
талант Та той шалений потенціал який
точно сприятиме глибинним трансформаціям
українського суспільства аби перетворити
його в те яке ми мріємо його бачити для
цього нам треба вивільнити цей потенціал
зокрема ми
провокуємо ми пропагуємо те що ставлення
до молоді коли молодій людині дають
можливість свідомо вибрати або ж
самостійно обрати і в той же час взяти
відповідальність прийняти
відповідальність за рішення яке молода
людина приймає А що ж чому чому це
важливо зрештою з 6 років тому назад Ми
почали шукати механізм який би допоміг
використовувати свободу та гідність яку
ми з вами відстоюємо вже понад 6 років а
і яка притаманна кожному з нас яка
глибоко в генах кожного українця з метою
того щоб мати потенціал молодої людини
на користь як самої людини так і на
користь суспільства і шукаючи краще
міжнародні практики ми натрапили на
модель яка називається Школа життя в
такій країні яка
достатньо схожа за контекстом тих
обставин яких перебуває Україна а саме
Ізраїль власне модель яка передбачає
дати можливість молодій людині яка
прагне бути частиною змін в суспільстві
додатковий рік по завершенню закладу
середньої освіти перед тим як молода
людина таки прийме рішення що робити
далі занурюватися у вищу освіту
занурюватись професійно освіту чи
скажімо йти працювати аби зробити певну
певної міри рефлексію рефлексію над
попередніми 11-ма роками свого життя які
відбувалися під патронатом батьків під
патронатом вчителів і в той же час
дивлячись вже і будучи однією ногою в
самостійному житті зрозуміти чого я хочу
що діється довкола і яким чином я що я
вмію і яким чином співставити те що я
вмію з тим що зараз потрібно і коли ми
думаємо про Україну Зазвичай ми думаємо
про країну яка повна викликів і через ті
виклики молодь втікає звідсіля в той же
час ми бачимо зі свого власного досвіду
якщо все ж таки прокомунікувати молоді
усі усю палітру викликів показати
можливість молоді об'єднуватись довкола
цих викликів Як між собою так і з
провідними експертами які змінюють Ну
тут і зараз а вона змінюється і з кожним
роком все більше і більше то
відповідальна молодь яка не боїться
відповідальності не тікатиме звідси Вона
братиметься за виклики які довкола нас
надихатиме нас своїм особистим прикладом
зокрема беручи і практикуючи
відповідальний лідерство яке починається
власне з рішення А що я робитиму який
внесок я зроблю в те щоби моє
суспільство змінювалось і Повірте в
16-17 років це саме той час коли ми
покликані поставити молодь на траєкторію
власного освітнього зростання який
власне мав би початися з цього
усвідомленого занурення в себе
проектуючи себе на зовнішній світ
зокрема на найближчу своє оточення а
саме українське суспільство і власне
наша місія місія Української Академії
лідерства може бути викладена буквально
в декількох словах які містять які ви
бачите на екрані а саме творимо себе
творимо Україну від якості кожного
окремого індивіда від окремої
особистості залежить якість суспільства
в цілому нижче ви бачите перелік
цінностей на яких сформована наша
програма людське суспільство - це є
власне
функціонування різноманітних
особистостей яке впорядко що вас не на
основі певних цінностей наше завдання
правителе українській молоді ці цінності
які допомагають їй в практикувати свою
свободу відповідально пізнаючи світ
довкола пізнаючи інших черпаючи мудрість
як тут під носом так і дивлячись на
практики кращих країн світу і в той же
час Відчуваючи гордість за те ким я є
абидувати тих людей до які довкола І в
які є в найближчому оточенні в тому в
той же час змінювати Україну та світ ми
доносимо і шукаємо молодих людей
насамперед які пізнають і приймають
мудрість про те що твоє життя в твоїх
руках життя твоєї країни тако ж для нас
очевидним є те що як тільки вдалося
ідентифікувати молоду людину яка готова
самостійно розвиватися і дати їй поштовх
в якості потужного соціального капіталу
мережі знайомств
унікального досвіду подорожей всередині
країни за межами країни тощо ця молода
людина здаватиме і ЗНО і найкраще і вона
обиратиме університет чи професійного
світу максимально свідомо тому що он вже
усвідомлює для навіщо їй це потрібно
коли молода людина має можливість задати
собі питання Навіщо мені потрібно те що
я робитиму далі адже позаду достатньо
великий період життя 11 років Попереду
ще більше і щоби не промахнутися або
принаймні зробити крок з меншим промахом
потрібно прорефлексувати і робити це з
тими людьми які тебе підтримують на
цьому шляху адже життя достатньо
турбулентна річ і воно ускладнюється з
кожним а тому вибір ускладнюється також
він вже є не настільки простим якби як
здавалося Чи нам хочеться щоб здавалось
надалі проте адже зміни незворотні кожен
навіть на прикладі пандемії роботи з
учнями відчув Наскільки швидко потрібно
було переорієнтуватися скажімо на роботу
онлайн на освоєння технологій і
наскільки складно подекуди було вчителям
які старалися попри всі обставини робити
свою роботу максимально якісно а
подекуди і дітям було складно
трансформуватися і не всім це вдалося
проте на цьому звичайному прикладі ми
бачимо що коли є особиста усвідомлена
відповідальність тоді буде якомога краще
результат Ми провокуємо молодь і
переконані що всі довкола повинні
провокувати молодь на пізнання на те щоб
на здатність молоді дивуватися на
здатність молоді роз очікувати рамки
тому і провокувати молодь до того щоб
пробувати нові речі і в той же час
створювати для молоді те середовище де
помилка толерується якщо молода людина
раптом падає є хтось поруч освітянин
ментор наставник хто допоможе встати про
рефлексувати над помилкою і рухатись
далі якщо ми подивимось скажімо на ту ж
саму країну Ізраїль чи силіконову долину
яка відома в світі завдяки інноваціям і
яка веде людство вперед в частині
технічного прогресу Там помилка
толерується помилка вітається на
помилках вчаться в нашому суспільстві
достатньо ще
довго потрібно працювати для того щоб ці
речі віталися а молодь сьогодні є
надзвичайно чутливою тому що в
віртуальному світі де вона занурена
цілковито і більше ніж будь-хто з нас з
вами аудиторії Вона бачить швидкі
Перемоги вона здобуває легкий результат
наживо життя складніше а тому маючи всі
ці обставини необхідно нам з вами вміти
коригувати власне підхід до роботи з
молодою людиною власне не лише про
молодь але також про суспільство в якому
ми живемо ми переконані що нам найбільше
як суспільство пощастило саме з молоддю
яка у нас є а тому для того щоб молода
людина
планувала свій вектор розвитку не лише
наодинці по відношенню до речі яка є
цікавить чи теми яка цікавить Ми
мотивуємо молодь подорожувати по всій
країні ми відкриваємо осередки
Української Академії лідерства по
периметру нашої держави і ми заставляємо
молоду людину зі Львова їхати на 10
місяців Харків з Маріуполя в Чернівці
тощо і створюємо досвід коли на 10
місяців ти занурюєшся в контекст
абсолютно іншого міста де ти ніколи не
був так що за ці 10 місяців це містечко
Чи це громада стає твоєю рідною або і
другою домівкою якщо ти відповідально
особистість яка планує стати чи то
лікарем чи той інженером чи то правником
чи то в майбутньому політиком ти будеш
практикувати відповідальний лист
розуміючи масштаб своєї країни її красу
і різноманіття людей які її населяють ви
ж без можливості подорожувати і бачити
не можна по-справжньому любити станом на
сьогодні Цей підхід він виправдовує себе
тим що в нас щороку зростає запит на
нашу програму в середньому 14 молодих
людей конкурують на те щоб потрапити на
10-місячну формаційну програму від
Української Академії лідерства яка є
нашим базовим продуктом А це краще
випускники
закладів середньої освіти а також ті
люди які вже закінчили заклад перший
курс навчання в закладі вищої освіти і
переосмислюють можливість рухатись далі
і шукають таку можливість саме в цьому
форматі романи я попрошую якщо можна вже
так звичайно для того щоб
продемонструвати можливість змінюватись
потребу змінюватись потрібно змінюватись
самому треба бути максимально справжнім
і мені дуже приємно бачити з ісландів
пана Ігоря власне ці приклади які можна
помацати молодь хоче бачити ці речі і
власне практикуючи
особисто відповідальну з в свій вектор
розвитку ми власне
базуємось на тому що для молоді потрібно
створювати ці особистий особливий досвід
досвід пізнання себе взаємодії спільною
колективної праці спільних мандрів адже
вас не поєднання оцього гібридного
досвіду і сприяє цим змінам і робить
молоду людину конкурентну спроможною в
XX I столітті яке з кожним днем лише
ускладнює наше життя а ми повинні вміти
відповідати на цій виклики зберігаючи
свою цілісність Дивлячись впевненістю в
майбутнє дякую дякую
кожен спікер дуже надихається неймовірно
Ну ми Я думаю що ми повернемося до
молоді Але таймінг у нас є таймінг тому
одразу передаю слово Альоні Тимошенко
керівниці першої української кіношколи
Ukrainian film school
Дякую всім
Я мабуть почну з того що Ми створюємо
українське кіно так
ми навчаємо процесу кіновибництва а кіно
це завжди емоція всі з нас всі ми йдемо
в кінотеатр для того щоб отримати емоцію
тому що трошечки вас можливо заразити чи
Показати цю емоцію про те як
відбувається процес навчання і хотіла
попросити включити відеоролик будь ласка
[музика]
ось приблизно та емоція яка панує в нас
в кіношколи і зараз будь ласка
презентацію
Ukrainian film School - це українська
кіношкола яка створена на базі
кіностудії film.ua це приватне кіно
школа і ми навчаємо кожного року десь
приблизно біля більше ніж 800 студентів
це студенти основних програм це студенти
короткострокових програм це так само
спеціальні програми для дітей і для
підлітків Ми запрошуємо більше ніж 50
лекторів щороку а можливо
це це цифра вона постійно змінюється
кожного року основні напрямки навчання
основні професії в кіновиробництві Це ті
які ви бачите на екрані і я хочу сказати
що це якраз
всі учасники кінопроцесу всі професії
всі головні професії всі автори всі
автори Які створюють
аудіовізуальний контент автори Які
створюють Цей фільм що все включає
процес нашого навчання як як взагалі
побудована система навчання ми кожного в
кожного курсу є куратор курсу він
створює разом з нами авторську навчальну
програму яка базується на його досвіді
куратор - це наш викладач наш лектор але
він перш за все людина Професіонал це
може бути це оператор Чи це режисер Чи
це актор Чи це продюсер Чи це сценарист
але він е-е людина яка працює на даний
момент в професії Він звичайно не має
звань немає зазвичай немає
професорських звань чи
інших регалії Скажімо так але він
сьогодні створює кіно і це те що ми
хочемо донести до наших студентів це те
чому ми їх навчаємо якраз практичного
досвіду і
відповідності
конкурентоспроможності ринку сьогодні на
даний момент Далі Ми створюємо
колаборації між курсами це те чого не
відбувається в реальному житті навіть у
процесі в кіно-виробництво коли
створюються продукт У нас дуже часто
сценарист не знає як зміниться його
сценарій і що він побачить уже на екрані
ми в кіношполі робимо все по-іншому ми
одразу під час першого місяця навчання
формуємо такі команди групи де є
представники всіх професій в нас наче
студенти виходять на пітчинги так само
як це можуть бути державні пітчинги в
держкіно чи пітчингів лукаф чи інші
різні грантові програми все Як все
відбувається як в реальному житті Тобто
ми працюємо в реальному часі вони
презентують свої проекти Вони захищають
свої ідеї Кожен з них хтось пише
сценарій хтось робить Хтось виконує
функцію режисера продюсера ми підбираємо
акторів з нашої кіношколи і ми
запускаємо цей проект вони через півтора
місяці вже виходять на знімальний
майданчик ми забезпечуємо їх професійним
обладнанням ми забезпечуємо їх локаціями
павільйонами ми забезпечуємо їх
костюмом реквізитом і через два тижні ми
вже бачимо на екрані той фільм який вони
створили протягом одного року ми бачимо
е-е протягом одного року студенти можуть
кожен студент створює близько 5 фільмів
тобто в кінці року Він отримує такий
шауріл із своїх робіт які може вже
презентувати і показати наскільки він
цікавий спеціаліст в даній професії в
галузі які на виробництво для будь-якого
продакшена чи кіностудії на ринку
наші викладачі - Це ті які працюють
сьогодні в кіноіндустрії я вже сказала
так що так само ми не забуваємо про
міжнародний досвід і ми залучаємо
міжнародних експертів або експертів з
Міжнародним досвідом які спілкуються з
нашими студентами і розказують про те що
відбувається в світі сьогодні Які є
фестивалі Які фестивалі хочуть бачити
фільми так які тренди відбуваються
сьогодні в кіноіндустрії що знімається
за скільки це знімається Скільки це
коштує і що ти хочеш робити Ти хочеш
бути автором авторського ти хочеш
створювати авторське кіно Чи ти хочеш
створювати комерційне кіно тоді ти
обираєш у нас в кіношколи Цей підхід і
одразу готуєшся до того щоб уже
стартувати в професію з навчання або під
час навчання
так трошки заплутались Вибачте це вже
сказала так само наші студенти коли
закінчують навчання ми
не покидаємо їх на цьому етапі ми завжди
тримаємо з ними зв'язок ми їх Запрошуємо
до себе на проекти ми їх рекомендуємо в
проекти наших колег Ми даємо можливість
їм потрапити на майданчик де я вам
можливість їм стажування і тому вони вже
далі можуть самі розвиватися самі
створювати свої проекти У нас є історії
успіху наших студентів за той час в які
ми навчаємося в кіношколі це лише
декілька прикладів так наприклад
випускниця
студентка нашого акторського курсу Вона
виконала головну роль в фільмі віддана
мабуть хтось чи Всі ви сподіваюсь бачили
тому що це наш український продукт
вироблений кіностудії film.ua до цього
дівчина працювала перукарем але й вона
якби так одразу потрапила в професію так
далі наші студенти створили чотири серії
документальних фільмів фантастичні
українці навчаючись в кіношколі під час
навчання це були випускні Студенти
нашого продюсерського курсу наші
студенти бачите
знайому абревіатуру нетфлікс так е-е
наші студенти актори знімаються в
міжнародних проєктах вони відповідають
тим міжнародним критеріям вони володіють
інформацією яка відбувається на ринку
міжнародному вони володіють англійською
мовою з тим акцентом який потребує
замовник і вони є конкурентоспроможні не
лише на ринку України а так само на
ринку міжнародному Я про кіно зараз
скажу Так випускник нашого
студента-курсу сценарист який до цього
займався it і був музикантом Він прийшов
до нас і зараз він пише Скажімо так дуже
важливий фільм для українського
кінопрокату це
тренера Лобановського і Стас є одним із
сценаристів цього проекту
на екрані є результати того що ми
зробили за цих 4 роки Школа була
створена в 2016 році зараз у нас п'ятий
набір але я завжди приділяю увагу не
тільки результат оприділяю увагу процесу
тому що процес в кіношколи ви знаєте
часто чую від випускників коли вони
закінчують що ми змінили їх життя Мабуть
це дуже такі якісь
слова Скажем так які Ну я завжди
сприймаю дуже відповідально але в
принципі я це бачу як це відбувається
вони їх Вони змінюють своє життя
професії Вони змінюють свою професію
вони в них є можливість нарешті отримати
ту мрію про яку вони мріяли з дитинства
тому що відсотків мабуть 80 тих хто
приходить вони всі кажуть що я в
дитинстві мріяв бути актрисою режисером
сценаристом А ось батьки мене просили
зараз я там 7 років закінчив в медичному
подарував батькам на випускний свій
диплом і прийшов до вас хочу бути
сценаристом вони є багато історій
готовий це писати тому ми надаємо
можливість
перекваліфікуватися Так зараз в нашому
сучасному світі Мені здається ми маємо
змінити відношення багато хто вже змінив
відношення до того що в нас немає бути
одна освіта людина в 17 років не може
обрати професію на все життя ми можемо
навчатися все життя ми можемо тричі ми
можемо 5 разів змінювати професію багато
людей в кіноіндустрії світові багато хто
з них немає диплому але вони відомі вони
їхні фільми дивляться збирають
бокс-офіси величезні Так це творча
Професія це професія ті які
для нас як для держави України які
Скажімо так транслюють нашу культуру які
візуалізують те що відбувається в
українському суспільстві які
популяризують нашу країну Україну І тому
ми повинні величезну увагу до цього
приділяти так Я наразі бачу
Скажімо так є проблеми в розвитку
освітнього процесу якраз в
аудіовізуальному секторі ми на минулому
тижні два дні провели з у нас була сесія
вищих навчальних закладів як
організовували держмитест і говорили про
те як потрібно все змінювати і які мають
відбуватися реформи і все-таки ви знаєте
вони сприймали мене там якоюсь мірою як
конкурента і я з ними погодилась хоча
ніколи раніше про це так дещо Ви не
відносились так український кіношкола
Зараз є конкурентом вищих навчальних
закладів тому що студенти і звищать
навчальних закладів профільних приходять
процес навчатися приходять для нас для
того щоб отримати практику і отримати
можливість працювати в професії чи вже
під час навчання чи одразу під час
навчання для цього не потрібно витрачати
5 років і можливо неможливо навіть більш
ніж впевнена що для деяких професій
наприклад акторська майстерність чи
продюсування не потрібно 5 років
університету Так це достатньо
одного-двох років і далі практики це ти
що ми даємо тому мені здається що зараз
можливо такі два варіанти розвитку і
варіанти зміни
тій ситуації яка зараз є вищі навчальні
заклади державні навчальні заклади вони
вони повинні надавати
матеріально-технічну базу достойну яка
відповідає сьогоденню так студенти які
до них приходять вони повинні навчатися
на професійному обладнанні на якому вони
зможуть працювати прийти на рентал і там
техні не буде їх навчати що таке камера
Як вона виглядає як вона повинна
працювати І все-таки вони мають
навчатися цьому на своїх лекціях але на
жаль цій матеріально-технічної бази
немає наче ВУЗи дуже часто відірвані від
того що відбувається на ринку сьогодні
вони не знають які є тренди вони не
знають які є гранти які є можливості для
студентів вони не знають яке кіно
знімається і як взагалі світ існує
сьогодні в них немає контакту з
індустрією це проте про це ми так само
неодноразово говоримо на круглих столах
і думаю про те як це створити так як
студентам потрапляти на майданчик на
після 5 років А уже під час навчання не
після того як він отримав диплом а з
перших днів ось тому тут Тут є таке дуже
болюче питання яке потребує максимальної
уваги для нас як для кіно школи для
представників неформальної освіти мені
в мене є таке велике прохання чи бажання
змінити умови кредитації для приватних
закладів вони не мають бути такими
самими як для вищих навчальних закладів
я про це думаю два роки я вивчила всі ці
правила всі ці умови і я розумію що ми
якщо Приймемо всі ці умови ми
перетворимося в один із вищих навчальних
закладів які є сьогодні тобто з тим
набором народних артистів професорів і
кандидатів але ці люди які не можуть
працювати на майданчику так вони не
можуть створювати кіно тому що вони
віддали там своє життя чи більшу частину
життя науці тому
Я вважаю що умови можуть переглядатися і
неформальна освіта вона буде достойною
конкуренцією і мабуть вона буде
провокувати ринок до того щоб він
розвивався змінювався і ми за цих
студентів між собою Скажімо так боролися
і відвойовували їхню увагу дякую дякую
насправді
насправді ось останнє Що ви сказали я
хотів одразу сказати Як гарно що вони
відчувають конкуренцію взагалі мені
здається що єдине що може рухати всю і
Державну систему і приватну будь-яку це
конкуренція і я дуже радію що ви з ними
зустрілися і вони відчувають цю
конкуренцію щодо акредитації і так далі
Я також Сподіваюся Ну мені здається що
зараз все якось почне рухатись з різних
сторін саме завдяки і неформальним цим
школами підходом тому що вже помітно
хвилюються помічають що на ринку таке
з'являється це це надзвичайно добре І
якщо ще й Знайдеться якась Гарна модель
взаємодії Гарна модель того щоб вищий
навчальний заклад починав не просто як
конкуренто розглядати і дивився
придивлявся до моделі а потім провокував
якраз якісь системні зміни щодо того що
там повинно бути квота на Ну я так
розумію по правилам повинна бути квота
стільки-то професорів стільки-то у них
там різних
статей і так далі І ось так Мені
здається за рахунок якраз сильних
неформальних установ це все буде
змінюватися і ще хочу сказати що не
тільки у вашій професії є Ось така
проблема з викладачами і так далі
педагогічне знання
найголовніше та найцікавіше публікуюся
англійською мовою і на жаль у нас Ну не
вся педагогічна спільнота знає
англійську мову тому вона також якби не
дуже в глобальному контексті один із
проектів які ми зараз плануємо робити це
якраз перекладати і робити вижимки із
західних педагогічних різних статей та
досліджень щоб хоча б вже їх починали
використовувати взагалі Тому це це така
загальна наша проблема що ми трішки
аутов де Global Contex проте я
сподіваюся що тут ми будемо рухатися
Дуже дякую надиха ючи як завжди у нас
немає нікого Хто б не надихав Світлана
Гриценко
Світлана Гриценко директорка освітніх
програм фонду Віктора Пінчука вам слово
дякую
Дякую дуже добрий день всім Я дуже рада
що зараз проходить цей форум коли ми три
дні Всі говоримо про освіту Ми говоримо
про доступ до освіти Ми говоримо про
якість освіти Ми говоримо про різну
освіту про державну освіту про
неформальну освіту Я хотіла поговорити з
вами сьогодні про А для чого освіта та
яка мета є освіта ми всі можемо мати
різні точки зору щодо розвитку нашої
країни до підходять до наш розвитку
нашої країни однак напевно ми сходимось
у тому що сьогодні Україна знаходиться
на стадії Коли зміне нам ще потрібні Да
ми маємо робити зміни і тому є такий
термін мабуть оці чули як чинжмейкерс та
зміна творці це люди які роблять зміну і
здебільшого це є молоді люди і саме тому
У фокусі роботи фонду Віктора Пінчука
вже понад 15 років є створення умов для
молодих людей аби саме вони могли стати
генераторами цих змін да робити зміни в
нашій країні
в різних галузях за різними масштабами
за різними напрямами
Ми реалізуємо цілий ряд програм які
дозволяють молодим людям Як розширити
свої кругозір як дозволяють їм отримати
саме безпосередньо освіту Наприклад ми
реалізуємо програму завтра.ua це
програма яка вже об'єднує понад дві з
половиною тисячі молодих людей з усіх
куточків в Україні які вибрали як
траєкторію оскільки ми сьогодні морем
про трактори освіти саме освіту в
Україну в українських закладах вищої
освіти і ці молоді люди отримують від
нас підтримку аби вони мали можливість
фокусуватися на освіті Вони стають також
частиною великої спільноти молодих людей
які об'єднують цінності підходи і вони
можуть Таким чином розбудовувати свої
мережі Вони мають можливість будувати
різні проекти Вони мають можливість
стримати додаткову освіту через тренінги
через навчання через практику вони
проходять волонтерство як в Україні вони
мають можливість також отримати практику
волонтерства за кордо ном на різних
заходах
іншою програмою яку реалізує фонд є
програма всесвітній студії це програма
для молодих людей які своєю траєкторії
освіти визначили освіту за кордоном а
саме магістерську освіту важливим у тому
важливим аспектом Я сказала для нас є те
що молоді люди які ми допомагаємо
отримати освіту за кордоном надаємо саме
їм гранти на магістерські програми у
найкращих університетах світу вони
зобов'язуються і підписують договір з
нами про те що після навчання вони
зобов'язані повернутися в Україну і
інвестувати свої знання Саме тут а у
разі якщо вони цього не роблять вони
зобов'язані повернути гроші або вони
могли бути реєстрований у інших молодих
людей
освіта за кордоном а потім долучення до
спільноти яка вже понад 100 молодих
людей які отримали сльози за кордоном
надає можливість
потужно нетворкінгу надає Можливість
створення на їх проектів реалізації і
зміни нашої країни також фонд Віктора
Пінчука реалізує серію публі чних лекцій
це великі проекти які вже участь взяли
більше 30 тисяч молодих людей коли
світолі лідери думок діляться і
спілкуються і мають можливість молодь
поставити запитання на різні теми за
різними напрями і почути світові
практики
ми вважаємо що важливо давати можливість
молоді реалізуватися і ми дуже всі
багато зараз говоримо про лідерство про
важливість лідерства молодих людей які
досягали але саме аспект лідерів отой
отакій частини лідерів які є
changeмейкерами які роблять зміни які
від тільки прагнення переходять до дії є
вкрай важливої для нашої країни і саме
тому ми вважаємо що треба допомагати їм
змінювати свої Свій дім Свій район своє
місце своє селище Україну і світ
майбутнього тому Давайте ми будемо
змінювати світ разом дякую
Дуже дякую пані Світлана і Наразі я хочу
передати слово безпосередньому учаснику
освітнього процесу
Василю Дяків педагогу Переможцю
національної премії Global Teachers
Price Ukraine 2020 і послухати Напевно
що ми послухаємо про роль учителя у
формуванні власної освітньої траєкторії
Якщо
так я думаю
Доброго дня шановне товариство Мені дуже
приємно що я вже вдруге виступаю на
такому побажному дійстві на такому
поважному форумі я вітаю всіх знайомих
тому що є справді люди які власне разом
із спільно зі мною і в команді працюють
саме над формуванням нового
процесу освітнього нової освітньої
системи
Що ж ми на сьогоднішній день маємо В нас
логіка сьогоднішнього виступу йде від
молоді і до дітей власне напевно так
воно і є Або так воно заплановане але
саме як сформована в дитинстві так
погляди погляди як сформовані навички як
сформовані підходи і принципи так і ми
будемо бачити це в наступних етапах
розвитку дитини і в наступних етапах
освітньої системи що ж Вітаю вас на
сьогоднішній день я буду говорити
винятково через власний досвід який є
дуже широким з однієї сторони а з іншої
сторони я попробую окреслити певні
виклики і десь прагнення і намагання їх
вирішити ну в конкретні конкретному
навчальному закладі де я працюю це
Заліщицька державна гімназія це також
своєрідний досвід досвід який локальний
і зрештою не тільки локальний але й він
проектується на державне на державний і
міжнародний рік Отож Давайте тоді
спробуємо окреслити Що таке
індивідуально освітня траєкторія
Звичайно Це якийсь сукупність якихось
інструментів які дають змогу
реалізовувати дитині свої здібності Ну і
свою мету або свою ціль звичайно як
формується індивідуально освітня
траєкторія це командна робота командна
робота - це насамперед сама дитина потім
батьки і педагоги чому бо тому що цей
взаємозв'язок Він якраз найбільш
оптимальний і найбільш ефективний для
реалізації цієї індивідуальної освітньої
траєкторії тоді спосіб реалізації я тут
погоджуюся повністю з паном романом і
іншими доповідачами про те що спосіб
реалізації - це насамперед метод пропі
помилку помилки не як
щось погане Так а ти як кажуть толерують
помилки з метою того щоби ця помилка
стала
сходинкою для розвитку подальшого
е-е своїх принципів підходів
компетентностей своїх ідей своїх цін Ну
і тепер пере до викликів Що ж ми маємо
на сьогоднішній день звичайно виходячи з
інтересного досвіду тобто з практики
виходячи з чисто емоційних суб'єктивних
вражень хотілося щоб науковці все ж таки
час від часу системно займалися цим
дослідженням тому що Наскільки швидко
зараз діти змінюються що дуже добре мати
якісь певні наукові дані для того щоб не
розуміли куди ми рухаємося з якої точки
в яку точку і зрештою як те що ми робимо
все ж таки сприяє зміні оціх даних ну що
ж перше Звичайно це дитина дитина це
теніал і відповідно Ця дитина яка має
свій цифровий світ звичайно яка бачить в
цифровому світі все дуже легко все дуже
просто яка не дуже задумується над тим
що буде завтра Ну і зрештою яка розуміє
що в житті має бути так само як це тут
це є проблема це є виклик і це є
серйозний виклик другий виклик Якщо ми
будемо говорити це низька педагогізація
батьків Чому тому що якби ми не казали і
про середню освіту і про душкільну і про
вищу і про професійну тобто про всі
етапи освіти Ми будемо говорити що все
закладається в дитинстві
і тут дуже важливим є і я це
постійно пропоную на різноманітних
майданчиках говорити про те що таке
освіта не тільки отак точку сьогоднішніх
три дні а говорити системою в яких
програмах Які би транслювали ідеї
держави бачення держави політику держави
і позитивні практики
Держава це дуже важливо чому бо тому що
тоді батьки починатимуть задуматися
починатимуть думати про те А навіщо І що
потрібно дитині і навіть вони почнуть
спілкуватися з дітьми тому власне
низький рівень педагогізації батьків це
є той виклик який на сьогоднішній день
не є вирішеним і саме системна робота
педагогів системна робота закладу освіти
і зокрема нашого дали змогу До речі
переконувати батьків у тому що дитина
має право на індивідуальну освітню
траєкторію це дуже класно І головне що
не тільки переконувати Але батьки тоді є
помічниками і є людьми які справді
підтримують але неперечать а розуміють
дитину її прагнення її бажання її напрям
що в нас ще є Звичайно це класно урочна
система класного урочна система вона
застаріла вона не дає змоги розвинути
дитину вона дуже обмежена у своїх
інструментах тому власне класно урочну
систему потрібно змінювати якщо ми
подивимося на позитивні практики вони
вони практично зорієнтовані це перше і
друге вони власне час найчастіше проєкт
Таким чином в себе було добре з
реалізацією індивідуального освітньої
траєкторії конкретної дитини ну якби не
було уроків ну це природній процес і це
нормальний процес на превеликий жаль
система поки що тримається до останку за
цей бастіон Чому Бо це є Монополія Ну і
це Монополія не дає можливо можливості
дитині і батькам власне реалізувати
власну освітню траєкторію от спосіб який
вони би визначили і за який принесли
відповідальність ще одне що у нас є як
висновок такий попередній освітня
система в Україні за окремими винятками
є консервативною І власне вона до певної
міри гальмує динаміку так гальмує сам
процес Ну що ж тепер давайте трошки
поговоримо про те що загального на
конкретно саме в 2003 році у нас
гімназії вперше Перепрошую якщо якщо
можна то хвилинку би буквально бо
таймінг можете Дякую добре дякую Отже
говоря по ці проблеми ми говоримо про те
що у нас чому наш навчальний заклад
бачить свої позитиве у тому що Ми
формуємо освітню траєкторію конкретної
дитини перше тому що у нас навчання
проводиться з 5 класу а це означає що Ми
змушені повинні мотивуємо себе до
конкуренції і до того щоб показувати ті
позитивні практики які дозволяють дітям
реалізувати себе в нашому закладі освіти
по-друге це можливість акцентованого
саме повідомлення інформування дітей про
той чи інший процес про той чи інший
власне своє бачення чи у свій спосіб
реалізації мети і зрештою ми досягнули
вагомих результатів можете тоді
подивитися і на сайті можете подивитися
і Facebook Ну І на завершення для того
щоб ми могли реалізувати
освітню траєкторію необхідна зусилля
команд політична воля і зрештою бажання
робити Україну кращою через призму
власне діяльності конкретної людини
конкретної молодої людини Ну і
конкретного громадянина Дякую за увагу
Дуже дякуємо
[оплески]
надзвичайно
цікава панель проте не вийшла дискусія
але я скажу чому Тому що у кожного тут
був настільки ну вражаючий великий
досвід що не хотілося просто переривати
тому що тут кожен справді просто тим про
що розповідав він відображав ту тему яка
і є і мені дуже приємно чути тези про
право на помилку тези про власні освітні
траєкторії тези от останні яка була
класноурочна система я вбачаю не просто
проблему у класному реченній системі А у
пасивно-декоративному стилі викладання у
цій класному розчинній системі те що ми
кажемо переход до команди до проектів це
активне навчання яке давно доведено що
працює набагато краще ніж просто
послухати лекцію і я сподіваюся що
зусиллями цих надзвичайних людей і ще їх
стає все більше і більше в нашій країні
ми все ж таки як полюбляють говорити про
лупай скалу і все у нас буде гарно Надія
є як мінімум Дуже дякую всім за увагу
Дуже дякую учасникам і я мов честь бути
тут також з вами і мені дуже приємно
дякую До побачення
дякуємо дякуємо усім нашому учасникам
Іллі хоч і не вийшло дискусія але завжди
вийде нетворкінг завдяки таким подіям де
можна обмінятися
думками і ідеями і можливо навіть певні
здійснювати проекти
логічним продовженням наших сесій і
обговорень стане наступна тема Буквально
за кілька хвилин тут на основній сцені
це освіта дорослих і освіта протягом
усього життя
82% українських учнів відповідальність
за власну освіту покладають на самих
себе директори шкіл відповідальними за
якісну підготовку учнів називають
учителів
93%, а потім себе
66%. такої ж думки батьки школярів
90%. батьки вважають що неякіс освіти у
школі також впливають комфортне
психологічне середовище так кваліфікація
педагогів це результати дослідження
проведеного на замовлення державної
служби якості освіти України
більшість учнів українських шкіл торік
перейшли на дистанційне навчання через
пандемію ковід-19 за підтримки
Міністерства освіти і науки та
Міністерства цифрової трансформації
запрацювало платформа всеукраїнська
школа онлайн вона розрахована на учнів у
5-11 класів тепер на цій платформі понад
півтори тисячі уроків і понад 167 тисяч
користувачів 125 тисяч учнів 34 тисячі
вчителів і більше ніж
8000 слухачів
право дітей з інвалідністю на здобуття
якісної освіти державної пріоритет
поточного навчального року в інклюзивних
класах українських шкіл навчається
більше ніж 25 тисяч учнів це майже в 10
разів більше ніж 5 років тому 43% шкіл
мають інклюзивні класи згідно з над
стратегією розвитку інклюзивної освіти
яку розробило міносвіти науки за 10
років усі заклади освіти мають
відповідати принципам безбар'єрності
це експозона форуму України 30 освіта і
наука і ми вкотре дивимося наскільки У
нас така розмаїта строката Скажімо так
наша експозона тому що далі ми приходимо
до теми аграрної і в системі
Національної академії наук України є
Інститут фізіології рослин і генетики і
ось пан Микола розкаже нам про новітні
розробки наших українських
певно сказати це науковці який
займається з селекцією пшениці зокрема
абсолютно точно А чим ви зараз найбільше
пишаєте вчора при відкритті цього форуму
президент Національної академії наук
академік Завгородній Анатолій глібович
одним з пріоритетних завдань визначив
все-таки дослідження пов'язаних з
забезпеченням продовольчої безпеки нашої
держави
і це справедливе визначення справедливі
пріоритет тому що продовольча безпека
сьогодні в світі Вона досить стоїть на
острові якщо взяти даний міжнародний
організацій та темпи приросту населення
дещо переїжджають темпи приросту
продовольства це зрозуміло ми
наближаємося до проблем розкажіть тому
що інститут відомий справді ми знаємо що
але що зараз нині над чим працюють
науковці інституту чим пишаєтеся які
саме сорти
вчений нашого інституту якому До речі
виповнюється в цьому місяці 75 років з
дня його заснування працюють над
створенням нових інноваційних розробок
пов'язаних із селекцією рослин це в
першу чергу основна продовольча культура
пшениці озима кукурудза титікалі горох і
деякі інші група культур ну домінуючої
культурою є озима пшениця сьогодні в
реєстрі сортів рослин селекції селекції
наших учених знаходиться Понад 120
сортів озимої пшениці
за зв’язку з змінами клімату
сортові ресурси вони дещо згруповані і
носять екологічний характер є
сортилісостепового типу є сорти
Степового Та типу є
сортизахідноєвропейського типу який
рекомендований для відповідних зон
виробництва другий напрям - це все-таки
продуктивність цих сортів якість
врожайність сьогодні урожайність наших
сортів вона перевищує 10-12 тонн зерна з
гектара рекорди вражаю отримані по
деяким нашим сортам і зафіксований як
досягнення це 14 т зерна озимої пшениці
з гектара третій такий напрям
пріоритетний на який сьогодні працюють
все-таки яких вже чином довести до
виробників до наших споживачів до наших
аграріїв ці стартові ресурси тому
інноваційне спрямування роботи інституту
вона являє є домінуючими і десь складає
60 до 70% всієї роботи творчого нашого
нашої установи сьогодні сортами селекції
інституту фізіології рослинні генетики
озимої пшениці засівається в Україні
понад два мільйона гектар площі це десь
в межах 30-32% загальної площі посіву
цієї культури Україні виробництво зерна
озимої пшениці із цих сортів нашої які
сьогодні внесені в реєстр перевищує 8
млн тонн це практично два раза
забезпечує продовольчу безпеку нашої
держави у продовольчому зерні
як буде час по уточнюю Але я думаю що
глядачам досить цікавий такий момент
можливо це не зовсім буде доречно але не
до вас Хоча це ця сфера і Можливо ви
знаєте від колег Я знаю що Світове
зерносховище воно на шпіцбергені але
була ідея пропозиція України ну це років
10 тому я точно Чув ви були певні
моменти пропозиції аби Про всяк випадок
для санітарною такою безпеки розмістити
подібне сховище в Україні чи є така
відповідь
кожний кожна селекційна установа Він має
банк генетичних ресурсів і сьогодні в
центр знаходиться в Харкові але ми як
селекційна установа як оригінатор маєм
світа сказати банк генетичних ресурсів
але наш піттсберги є наші сорти які
знаходяться в цьому сховищі також потому
що ми вчасно приймаємо участь
міжнародних програмах пов'язаних із
селекцією рослин добре ви сказали що до
стійкості сказали тому що це зрозуміло і
тим людям які навіть не дуже в темі е-е
Зай там ботаніки але принаймні такі речі
що є зонування і той сорт який добре
може бути лісостепах чи на підзолистих
ґрунтах військових на в Лісовій зоні А
все ж таки може не прижитися в степах А
те що більш сухостій от зараз який у вас
акцент в рамках цієї продовольчої
безпеки і я знаю що Чому я кажу щоб
вийти за межі України тому що інститут
зокрема і ваша продукція результати
досліджень вони викликають зацікавлені і
за кордоном значить дійсно це
справедливе запитання за останні роки ми
спостерігаємо ну 20-25 років ми
спостерігаємо на території нашої держави
різке змінна зміни клімату Ну якщо
навіть сказати температурний режим він
дещо збільшився в сторону плюс якщо
взяти зона степи в сума ефективних
температур зона лісостепу зона Полісся
то сьогодні зона ефективних температур
завітаційний період в зоні лісостепу
вона зрівнялася із зоною степу і плюс
додамо е-е те що став більш
континентальним кліматом це означає що
можливо не кількість попить навіть
кількість опадів за рік може бути та
сама але вони випадають на рівномірно то
за місяць Злива так що ну місячна за
день працюючим фактором всі ситуації є
послуга і якраз створення
цілого цілого Плеяди сортів пов'язаних
із жаростійкістю посухостійкості для
зони степу лісостепу вона є найбільш
актуальними для нас для цього
використовуються сучасні молекулярний
генетичних дослідження ми тісно
співпрацюємо з нашими зарубіжними
партнерами сьогодні наші сорти є крім
того що зареєстрований в Україні вони
сьогодні присутні за кордоном це зокрема
Молдова це е сьогодні Випробування йде в
Казахстані сьогодні тестуються наші
сорти в Туреччині Я думаю що ближчим
часом Ми будемо присутні на
Європейському ринку також ще от останні
важливе питання ми люди як істоти зараз
от всі переживаємо вже більше року
боремося з цією планетою із
коронавірусом і вже думаємо наперед
Наскільки треба розвивати цю науку і
вірусологію і мікробіології багато інших
питань фармацевтику і так далі але разом
із тим у рослин зокрема пшениці є свої
хвороби і є свої шкідники плюс Та ж сама
міграція залишається і завдяки птахам і
людям і так далі І так далі тому що
мобільність населення зокрема на планеті
досить висока наскільки наука встигає за
цим тому що там теж шкідники адаптуються
як і віруси для людини на жаль ви добре
здаються дійсно
поряд із створенням сортів в нас і такі
напрям як агробіотехнології тобто
розробка елементів сортових технологій
по кожному сорту сорт - це індивідум це
як людина має різні так сказати
відмінності так і кожної сотні для
кожного сорту є елементи технології це і
пов'язані із захистом від хвороб
пов'язаних із захистом від шкідників а
також
забезпеченням максимальної
продуктивності того чи іншого сорту
відповідної зоні дякуємо вам за
рогоспіті я сподіваюся що нашим глядачам
можливо це буде цікаво ознайомитися і на
сайті інституту із книжками які є тому
що це надзвичайно цікава наука якраз та
сфера обов'язково на коровай Точно Дякую
знання - це скарб а вміння вчитись ключ
до нього українська освіта змінюється
вона стає гнучкішою і сучаснішою
цифровою і безбар'єрними наука все
більше цікавить молодь розробки і
винаходи перетворюються на стартапи а
держава підтримує і мотивує
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 освіта і
наука
з українськими форумі Україна 30 разом
із експертами ми поговоримо про освіту
дорослих як власне ідея парадигма
безперервної освіти протягом усього
життя втілюються в Україні і на рівні
такої традиційної для нас освіти
інститутів підвищення кваліфікації і так
далі завершуючи вдалими результативними
прибутковими
бізнес-проектами які пов'язані із
освітою для дорослих людей які готові
інвестувати у свої знання і навички я
прийду слово модератору цієї дискусії це
обговорення Артем Нікіфоров журналіст
секретар громадської ради Міністерства
освіти і науки України
2012-2014 років
Дякую Дмитра і вітаємо вас колеги Під
час цієї панельної дискусії будемо
говорити про освіту для дорослих і перш
ніж ми представимо вам учасників нашої
панельної дискусії Є пропозиція до самих
учасників під час виступів якомога
активніше зосередитися не тільки над
констатацією тієї проблематики яка є бо
ми всі більш-менш обізнані з цього
приводу а все ж таки над тими а-а
шляхами вирішення які лежать не тільки в
площині треба збільшити фінансування бо
ми знаємо що більше грошей менше проблем
а як можливо з практичної точки зору нам
підійти до того що ситуація в нас буде
набагато і набагато краще давайте ми для
початку представимо наших учасників це
Вадим свириденко уповноважений
президента України з питань реабілітації
учасників бойових дій п Вадиме вітаємо
Тетяна Сахарук генеральна директорка
глобального договору ООН в Україні
Тетяно вітаємо
Володимир рупцов президент міжнарод його
благодійного фонду міжнародний фонд
соціальної адаптації пане Володимире
вітаємо Василь Кремень президент
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України п Василю вітаємо Анатолій
Заліський ректор Чернігівського
обласного інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти імені Ушинського
вітаємо вас пане Анатолію і Олексій
Мірошниченко виконавчий віце-президент
конфедерація роботодавців України пане
Олексію вітаємо вас колеги Є пропозиція
встановити регламент виступу до семи
хвилин почуємо наших учасників і після
цього матимемо змогу почути запитання
від учасників один до одного і можливо
навіть будуть запитання із зали ми вас
до цього заохочуємо і перше слово першу
скрипку надаємо Вадиму свириденку
уповноваженому президента України з
питань реабілітації учасників бойових
дій пане Вадиме
з фронту повертаються українці постає
питання про те чим їм займатися далі Це
складне питання хочеться почути вашу
думку як фахівця чи дійсно наші ветерани
мають можливість безперешкодно або
здобути новий фах або перенавчитися і
відчувати себе комфортно враховуючи ті
труднощі з якими вони зітхаються просимо
насправді 14-го року перед державою
стало таке складне завдання як
відновлювати учасників бойових дій і що
робити з ним далі ми часто почали
вживати такі терміни як реабілітація
реінтеграція дебріфенги І дійсно освіта
- це одне з важливих таких пунктів де
учасник бойових дій може відновитися
перш за все Я хотів би сказати що
атовці які повертаються з зони бойових
дій вони відчувають от гостроту
недопрацювання в законодавчій базі
гостро для того що є якась
несправедливість вони хочуть це все
змінити але на жаль не всім це вдається
тому що дійсно ну щось з проблематикою
ми маємо розуміти що перш за все це
зміни в законодавчій базі зміни в
постановах якраз тут і постає як
правильно оцю людину навчити і
перенавчити тому що
не має такої широкої можливості немає
системи вона недоопрацьована от Ну
наприклад прикладом є те що державних
закладах на сьогоднішній день можна
тільки навчатися на денній формі
навчання і я вважаю що це от
недопрацювання тому що все ж таки дуже
вік який от був в зоні бойових дій
учасники бойових дій - це було
15-16 років це 35-45 років і все ж таки
люди які повернувшись мають не тільки
навчатися а мають і
утримувати свої сім'ї думати Як далі
жити вони не можуть повноцінно от
віддати все навчання тому я вважаю що це
треба розширити і дати можливість
навчатися і в заочній формі Ось і все ж
таки торкаючись питань навчання я хотів
би сказати думку мабуть багатьох
ветеранів дайте більше можливості щоб
дійсно ветерани йшли як мені не тільки в
Міністерства це можуть бути
ті від самого такого маленького
де вони можуть займатися займати якісь
місця це в районних радах і до
міністерств де дійсно це буде їхній
потенціал їхні зміни на сьогоднішній
день я хотів би щоб такі
робочі заклади більше працювали з
громадським організаціями у нас на жаль
дійсно дуже багато ветеранських
організацій де і це наш недолік е-е де
куди входять наші ветерани і інколи
важко довести цю інформацію до ветерана
які заклади дійсно можуть надати ту чи
іншу допомогу і ветеранів треба долучати
як до юридичної частини до економічної
ну
тут же ж можна ще
багато до- додавати і міжнародні
організації які нас сьогоднішній день
співпрацюють з ветеранами ми знаємо дуже
багато таких проектів як
україна-норвегія втрати фонд НАТО якісь
дійсно допомагають і при навчанні
учасників бойових дій особливості
трастов Я хочу підкреслити трастовий
НАТО тому що я дуже багато працюю по
різним проектам з ним з ними
і це дуже важливо коли в такі проекти
коли учасник бойових дій повертається з
зони бойових дій і йому не дають такі
можливості але на жаль це мало
інформації все ж таки тут має бути такий
міжвідомчі формати і Міністерство освіти
має більше працювати з міністерством
ветеранів от І мені хотілося б щоб це
навчання у нас було безперервним
вирішуючи одним проблему ми ставимо інші
завдання інші проблематики вони самі
з'являються насправді І тут якраз оці
проблематики можуть вирішувати учасники
бойових дій які Бачили які знають як це
вирішувати Ну у нас дуже є позитивний
такий приклад
учасники бойових дій які отримали
враження інвалідність який пройшли за
кордоном реабілітацію
на собі відчули як це
перенавчатися як це відновлюватися як
почати жити новим життям вони йдуть
навчатися реабілітологами і ви знаєте це
дійсно фахівці з'являються на з великої
букви У нас уже пішли
багато закладів які дійсно готують
реабілітологів і там зараз навчаються
учасники бойових дій я вам скажу що перш
за все перш за все тут працює Програма
така психологічна побратим побратимом це
Довіра довіра до психолога учасника
бойових дій довіра до фізичної
реабілітолога він повністю розкривається
і учасник бойових дій отримавши травму і
Це сприяє швидкому і покращення його
здоров'я тому я вважаю що дійсно такі
програми мають розвиватися наша
співпраця між міністерством має бути
настільки щоб дійсно на це відчули
ветерани на собі і дайте можливість
ветеранам більше
входити в цю систему задовольняйте їх
потреби дайте можливості і я гадаю що
ветерани будуть той потяг який будуть
змінювати загальну систему навчання і
освіти Дякую вам а Дякуємо вам Вадима ми
потім відведемо на запитання від
учасників дискусії і учасників від зали
а п Вадиме коротко Я правильно розумію
що з точки зору державної політики
державного регулювання ветерани з точки
зору здобуття освітніх послуг вони не
виокремлені в окремо категорію вони такі
самі як і всі інші дорослі Ні у нас є
пільги пільги але вони недостатньо це як
для ветеранів также і для їх дітей є
пільги де дійсно вони держава Вона
створила пільги але вони
недопрацьовані тобто система повноцінно
на 100% не працює приватні заклади вони
самі вирішують скільки туди можна додати
місць для ветеранів яка кількість як
вони будуть навчаться це буде денна
заочно але держава має все-таки
попрацювати над тип щоб покращити
навчання для учасників бойових дій
Дякуємо вам Вадима Ну ви як
уповноважений президента будемо
сподіватися що після ваших слів цієї
співпраці між міністерствами буде більше
бо якщо про це говорить повноважений
президента то мають почути Дякуємо вам
пане Вадиме Тетяна Сахарук генеральний
директорка глобального договору ООН в
Україні п Тетяно вам запитання не
ставимо У вас є презентація тому просимо
одразу почнете
Дякую я підхоплюю п Вадима і продовжую
цю тематику починаючи зі слова тренди
Сьогодні я б хотіла розпочати з цілей
сталого розвитку чоловіки Україна
повинна виконати до 2030 року і сьогодні
на конференції України 30 маємо говорити
про ті цілі одна з них - це якісна
освіта четверта ціль а також 11 - це
сталий розвиток міст та громад яким
чином через освіту можна розвивати міста
та громади глобальний договір ООН в
Україні протягом 2020 року здійснив
проект який ми називали it Nation проект
здійснювався на території Донецької та
Луганської областей і мав на меті
залучити принаймні тисячу осіб для
навчання
it освіті з нуля і наше цільова
аудиторія була люди від 15 до будь-якого
іншого віку Тобто вона була досить
розширеною
мир стартували з початком пандемії з
початком карантину і попри
цілі тисячу людей ми набрали дві понад з
половиною тисячі людей які записалися на
проходження цієї програми
Це було дуже цікавий досвід для того щоб
зрозуміти що цікавість в ІТ освіті лише
в одному регіоні вона є до нас
записалися Люди різного віку це було і
15-річні А це були і жінки і чоловіки це
були і ветерани це були і люди похилого
віку
цікавим є те що половина цих людей це
жінки і більшість жінок які зайшли на
програму це люди
понад 30 років і часто це жінки з вищою
освітою
це говорить про те що Якщо раніше
чоловік заробляв кошти для родини і
забезпечував її тож приходом кризи з
приходом військових дій з закриттям
підприємств жінка зрозуміла що вона
також повинна займатися справами родини
і
намагатися заробляти кошти для того щоб
родина мала на що існувати
ми подумали яким чином це можна
розвивати в громаді якщо людина не хоче
переїжджати в інший регіони і зрозуміли
що це повинна бути дистанційна робота ми
розробили разом з партнерами
спеціалізований курс який протягом шести
місяців
якщо людина працює кожного дня надавав
достатньо навичок для того щоб працювати
або тестувальником або розробником
у нас було 5 напрямків за якими люди
обрали куди ж вони саме повинні йти
крім шести місяців освітньою програми на
платформі яка була повністю дистанційною
ми забезпечилище певну кількість
вебінарів з софт Skills Hard Skills для
того щоб людина не лише отримала певні
знання в
it-сфері але й знала яким чином можна
просувати себе на ринку праці
на хакатоні Ми підключили багато велику
кількість компаній які долучилися для
того щоб дати завдання людям і
подивитися якщо люди справді можуть
запропонувати певне рішення в it-сфері
то такі компанії могли б запропонувати
робоче місце випускникам цієї програми і
ми дійсно отримали досить непогані
результати наприкінці програми коли
отримали понад 700 випускників половина
з яких майже половина з яких все ж таки
жінки і це люди які змогли потрапити до
it бізнесу це люди які стартували зі
своїми
it-проектами і навіть проект який зараз
працює на глобальний договір ООН
розробляючи грузі сталого розвитку для
студентів вищих
Ось так вона виглядає і керівник групи
яка розробляє цю гру це жінка яка
закінчила наші курси їй 49 років Вона
все життя пропрацювала вчителькою зараз
вона створила команду з шести
розробників та тестувальників і вони
створюють
it-продукти для різних клієнтів Таким
чином виходячи лише з однієї програми
яка
продовжувалася протягом лише одного року
ми бачимо що
українське населення здатне сприймати
діджитальну освіту воно може навчатися
дистанційно і це не залежить від віку
людей які навчаються ми бачимо що є
попит як від жінок так і від чоловіків і
Незалежно від того чи була раніше
отримана освіта ними Тобто ми йдемо в
світовому тренді коли людина навчається
протягом всього життя на жаль
не підтримують чи не недостатньому рівні
підтримує це цей напрямок освіти
протягом всього життя якщо ми подивимося
на результати дослідження яке в минулому
році Україна презентувала перед системою
ООН про досягнення цілей сталого
розвитку то одним з показників там є
освіта протягом всього життя і якщо ми
ставили собі одні показники які ми
повинні були досягнути до 2020 року то в
цьому дослідженні показано що ці
показники навіть упали порівняно з 2015
роком і це дуже негативний тренд тому
Через такі організації як наша через ті
фонди про які говорив пан Вадим
напередодні
йде популяризація освіти протягом всього
життя серед населення України Я вірю що
наше населення здатне змінюватися і
здатне підвищувати економічне зростання
своїх РЕ держави в цілому Дякую за увагу
Дякуємо Тетяно Тетяну ви сказали про те
що держава має більше приділяти уваги що
саме
освіта популяризувати цю освіту протягом
всього життя бо в Києві Наприклад ми
бачимо досить багато розвісити на
телебаченні навчайтеся як правильно і це
теж потрібно Бо в Києві є певні тренди
люди більше відвідують різноманітних
курсів чи івентів Якщо ж ми заглянемо
десь в селище навіть 40 км від Києва ми
бачимо що там недостатньо інформованості
населення з приводу можливостей для
людей які старші Я не знаю за 20 років
тому це потрібно популяризувати і в
інформаційному полі також ну Тетяна
бачите з приводу не
поінформованості в нас в Україні дуже
високий рівень антивакцинальних настроїв
тому ми тут не можемо всіх переконати а
тут завдання стає ще більше глобальним
безумовно Володимир Дякуємо вам
Володимир рупцов президент Міжнародного
благодійного фонду міжнародний фонд
соціальної адаптації п Володимире
просимо
дякую за запрошення если позволить её
коротко проекте в начале скажу А потом
скажу чтобы хотелось чтобы учить работу
в этом направлении
Норвегия финансирует проект социальной
професійної адаптации военнослужащих и
членов семей 2003 года
за это время его участниками стали
примерно 12,500 человек
проект начался э-э да Вот финансирует
его министерстве иностранных дел
координатор міжнародний фонд социальной
адаптации в Украине У нас есть партнёр
это университет норвежский университет
Норд Ну вот цифру я сказал и с 2015 года
категории военнослужащих ещёновых семей
добавилось ещё участники
антитерористической операции Операция
обидённых сил которая на сегодняшний
день участниками проекта стали
2376 человек
какие направления основные
это переподготовка по времени это 500
академических часов потому что згідно
Закону Про социальный правовий захист
військовослужбовців членов их семей
військовослужбовець который высушил 10+
років Имеет право получить возможность
пройти переподготовку на цивільну
специальность в объёме неменее 500
академических часов поэтому 500 3 месяца
при підготовка зачисляет к университет
мы поддерживаем инициативы университета
значит инициативой громадской
организации которая работает совместно с
ним инициативой местной власти и самих
участников они выбирают направление
переподготовки мы помогаем им с
координировать деятельность перевести в
соответствие с действующим
законодательством вот помогаем набрать
соответ кваліфіцированих спеціалістів в
університетах слідів за тем чтобы
уровень - это не был мнения чем мы э-э
договорились и вот по
распределению направлении переподготовки
вы можете увидеть что в основном это
мало бизнес и информационные технологии
в малом бизнесе то есть более 70%
участников нашего проекта - это
військовослужбовцы члены их семей
участники боевых дней день и члены их
семей Вот они выбирают такие направления
проект начался в Севастополе в 2003 году
за тем в восьмом году финансирование с
норвежской стороны было передано от
Министерства Обороны министерстве
иностранных дел что дал резкий скачок
развитие проекта мы вышли из Крыма
оставшись там по- практически в 24
городах Крыма мы работали и вышли в Киев
запорожье-мелитополь на материковой
части в
году когда Крым был захвачен мы вывели
проекты с Крыма и в течении двух месяцев
мы его разместили на материковые части
Украины сегодня это -
21 город 21 міста 21 университет и 19
громадских организаций партнёров этого
нашего проекта в чём его особенность вот
модель размещена здесь во-первых проект
полностью финансового самодостаточно нам
не нужно от государства дополнительного
финансирования все этапы начиная от
информационного обеспечения набора груп
выбор направления переподготовки сама
переподготовка которая считает
вниверситет в комплексе с мероприятиями
про э-э
психологической адаптации правовой
адаптации по содействую трудоустройства
открытие собственного бизнеса
осуществляет общественной организация то
есть громадская организации университет
работает тендеми постоянно и когда
університет через три месяца с половиной
заканчивает э-э обучающую часть
громадская организация продолжает
работать с участниками проекта на
протяжении года
особенность этого э-э этой модели
заключается в том что во-первых мы
обучаем не только в військовослужбовцы
не только участника боевых дней день но
и семью мы считаем Что именно семья Вот
тот Объект на который надо обратить
особое внимание Вадим совершенно
правильно сказал основное основной
возраст 35-45 лет это работа способная
ещё умные грамотные люди и слово
переподготовка Ну я вам сказал не совсем
может быть здесь точно потому что эти
люди достаточно много знают много и
умеют им надо помочь раскрыть свои
внутренние резервы надо подсказать
направить Не путём просто обучение а
путём именно сотрудничества путём поиска
совместных направлений
по развития поэтому на этапе отбора у
нас осуществляется примерно Ну это месяц
полтора
индивидуальная работа с каждым будущим
участником боевых действий и участникам
э-э
участников нашего проекта и когда они
формируются в группы идёт групповая
работа там работа психолога параллельно
с обучением идёт работа специалистов по
працевлаштуванию все
выпускники без исключения разрабатывают
и защищают бизнес-план который является
обязательном итогом направления
переподготовки э-э
предприя- предприямской діяльності
который в дальнейшем участвует в На
открытом конкурсе равных возможностей на
областных конкурсах поддержки стартапов
а-а бизнес-проектов это очень важно далі
следующая особенно заключается в том что
громадская организация постоянно
работает с университетом
основной упор по
психологическому климату в коллективе по
мотивации участников проекта к
самостоятельной и само занятости и
дальнейшем активному продвижению и
громадская организация она тестно
работает с местной власти одна из задач
громадской организации обеспечить соь
финансирование проекта из местных
бюджетов на уровне 20% 30 секунд
буквально
всё замечательно учимся работаем э-э
чтобы чтобы хотелось Хотелось бы чтобы
вот эта модель которая всеми уже э
признано принята и оценено чтобы она
каким-то образом всё-таки была
воспринята державою і интегрированная в
державній программы которые возможно как
нам обещала Министерство справах
ветеранов будут разработаны консул 2022
года Дякую за увагу Дякую вам пане
Володимире
коротко
конкурс учасників на одне місце який во
Львові 10 человек на место Значит в
Одессе примерно полтора вот в Чернигове
тут сидят наши руководители проекты
совершенно случайно Я оказались в этом
зале но у них Как правило два-три
человека на одно место конкурс приймайте
Дякуємо вам п Володимире Запрошуємо до
слова п Василь Кремень президент
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України п василівно ви займаєтеся не
побоїмося слова зокрема розробкою
політики щодо освіти дорослих що ви
бачите не з точки зору проблем а що нам
треба зробити так щоб от три попередні
промовці наступного форуму сказали все
супер все вирішено запитань немає
просимо Дякуємо Шановні колеги саме
поняття освіта дорослих має відносно
недовго історію але
потреба в освіті дорослої людини вона
багатовікова і євреї була в різних
суспільства одначе Я хочу це підкреслити
ніколи раніше
освіта дорослих не мала такого значення
Як сьогодні і це не Чия спримха
це
результат того що людство вступило в
новий інноваційний тип прогресу
інноваційний тип прогресу який
характеризується надзвичайно швидкою
динамічною зміною умов життя діяльності
людини зміною ідеєю знань технологій так
інше такою зміною яка відбувається
значно скоріше ніж
за одне людське життя моє свідками цього
я не буду це ілюструвати І тому ми
повинні готувати
інноваційну людину Я хочу це підкреслити
на превеликий жаль в суспільстві
розуміння цієї проблеми ще недостатньо
іноваційну людину тобто людину з
інноваційним мисленням з інноваційною
культурою і особливо що важливо
здатністю до інноваційного типу
діяльності а це завдання вимагає змін і
в традиційній освіті і вимагає серйозної
організації освіти дорослих Якщо
говорити про традиційну освіту скажімо
про шкільну освіту то окрім функції
традиційної функції критично творчо
засвоєння певної Суми базових знань як
мінімум ще дві функції актуалізуються
друга функція - це функція навчити
дитину навчатися впродовж життя виробити
уміння навички потребу навчатися
отримувати інформацію людина розумна
гомоса в XXI столітті це та людина яка
постійно навчається навчання отримання
інформації її використання повинно бути
однією з ключових ознак способу життя
сучасної людини і третя функція
навчального процесу це навчити людину
знання використовувати в практичній
діяльності в побуті професійній і таке
інше ми проаналізували в академії як
виступають на міжнародних предметних
олімпіадах наші діти там де потрібно
продемонструвати певну суму знань ми
серед найкращих там де потрібно показати
як застосувати базові знання для нас
зв'язок конкретної проблеми тим більше
нетипової отут у нас єсть проблеми і А
цей шлях до формування знаннєвої людини
знаннєвого суспільства коли знання
набувається не для ЗНО не для іспиту а
набувається для того щоб вони були
основою така діяльності поведінки кожної
людини тепер щодо освіти дорослих освіта
дорослих повинна стати
обов'язковою і широко організованою які
тут проблеми потрібно вирішити в першій
час
перш за все я відповідаю на питання
перше
утвердити в громадській думці освіту
дорослих як найбільш надійний шлях до
кращого і самореалізації людини і до
кращого до успішного життя тут потрібно
серед іншого шанувати людину знання
шанувати кваліфіковану людину на
превеликий жаль непрофесійність набула
скажімо
широко розповсюдження нашому суспільстві
в останні роки десятиліття не буду про
це говорити друге що потрібно зробити
створити механізм зацікавлення людини в
освіті створити механізм
який би спонукав людину чи вона працює в
державній структурі чи вона працює в
приватника на те щоб навчатися і тут ми
повинні серйозним чином попрацювати з
приватним сектором Я думаю Олексій
Мірошниченко скаже пізніше на превеликий
жаль є люди приватники які підприємці
які кажуть я плачу налог і цього досвід
Все замість того щоб внести необхідний
вклад в підготовку у підвищення
кваліфікації своїх людей третє потрібно
створити широку розгалужену мережу ринку
освітніх послуг
це і те що колеги тут говорили прекрасні
приклади це то це і особливі навчальні
заклади і я хочу підкреслити Це ті
навчальні заклади традиційні які існують
але які повинні скажемо профтек заклад
не обмежуватись двох-трьохріччям
навчанням університет чотирьохрічним
п'ятирічним навчанням розвинутих
університетах сучасного світу існують
програми від трьох днів до трьох тижнів
трьох місяців і таке інше і людина
обирає собі програму оплачує кошти і
отримує послугу Ми повинні спонукати
ВУЗи до такого життя громадська
організація Я є президент товариства
знання України я міг багато розказати
наскільки товариство робить скажімо
з'являється нові вимоги я в області
фінансового обліку ми підвищили
кваліфікацію буквально тисяч бухгалтерів
які працюють різних в різних сферах
четверте річ необхідно це Підготовка
фахівців з освіти дорослих Мені дуже
приємно повідомити що за наполяганням
Національної академії під наук 2 роки
назад в Україні
узаконена професія андрагог тобто
педагог освіти дорослих і чотири
університети вже їх готують п'яте
розроблення спеціальних методичних
методично їх прийомів методики навчання
дорослих каже Тут є специфіка від того
що це самостійні люди до того ще це люди
з потужним минулим знаннями які також
треба використати для їх подальшого
навчання і ще одне надзвичайно важливе
створення центрів оцінювання
результатів освіти дорослих і видання
спеціальних Тобто це п Васильович да
спеціальних спеціальних документів які
свідчать про нарощення кваліфікації у
нас є гарні приклади уже тут називалось
буде йти мова про інститути
післядипломної педагогічної освіти ямі і
говорити про університет менеджер той
світив нашої академії це 7 000 кожний
рік підвищує кваліфікацію
академії існує інститут педагогічної
освіти і освіти дорослих на базі якого
кафедра Юнеско за освіти дорослих на
базі якого асоціація освіти дорослих ви
Закликаємо до співпраці і буквально
останні що я хотів сказати треба
поширювати рух світовий рух міст що
навчаються в Україні є 7 таких міст Я
думаю що з'являться нові Я думаю що ті
проблеми про які говорив і про які я не
встиг сказати вони е-е вони вони значній
бері скоріше вирішувались якби Той закон
про освіту дорослих який підготовлений
міністерством освіти науки спів з
національної академії педагогічних наук
України був би якнайскоріше прийняти
Верховною Радою Дякую за увагу п Василю
приймається коротке запитання ви
говорите про те що от має бути
зацікавленість у суспільстві освіти
впродовж життя а чи не є елементом
проблеми що цього не Відбувається те що
давайте всі визнаємо у нас вище освіта
багато коли відіграє соціальну а не
економічну чи освітню функцію тобто коли
дитину відправляють в інститут щоб
поселити в гуртожиток щоб в їй на 5
років чимось зайняти і вищі які зайняті
тим що фактично опікуються долею людини
5 років а не готують фахівця вони можуть
зосередити увагу на більш глобальних
проблемах як освіта для дорослих ви
знаєте вони повинні це робити але я
скажу більше Навіть є
вищі навчальні заклади перш за все не
державної форми власності окремі із них
є серед них добрі заклади Але є такі які
практично торгують дипломами про вищу
освіту не опікуючись ні дітьми Ні їх
освітою і таке інше тому от те що
Міністерство освіти науки в останній час
намагається підвищити вимоги до
університетської освіти - це правильно я
вважаю що потрібно можна створити
обласних центрах потужний регіональний
національний університет більшості
обласних центрів - це один університет
на основі об'єднання того що є і тоді
буде легше е-е заохотити додам до
навчання бо там будуть потужні наукові
школи там не буде викладач читати 5-10
предметів що це таке за за наука що таке
за освіта я навчався в Київському
університеті де один викладач читає один
предмет приймайте про ці проблеми
безумовно знаємо І дійсно їх повинні
вирішувати а-а Дякуємо вам Анатолій
залісський ректор Чернігівського
обласного інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти імені Ушинського
пане Анатолію ми знаємо що у вас відео
Да ви підготували а зроблю вступне слово
коротенького на хвилинку а потім
Прокоментуйте питання щоб ми не дивилися
тільки відео Поки воно буде
відображатися щоб ви його коментували за
можливістю і перетворили це на вашу
презента ми просимо Добре дякую Я
декілька слів потім попрошу включити
відео Доброго дня всім присутнім Дуже
дякую організаторам за запрошення за
можливість поспілкуватись мабуть Всі ви
зі мною погодите що успіх реформи нової
української школи залежить від
реалізації трьох основних напрямків чи
чинників які зараз перерахую для того
щоб реформа була успішною важливо мати
новий зміст освіти якісний зміст освіти
- це нові стандарти нові навчальні плани
і програми це нові підручники Потрібно
також мати нового вчителя підготовлено
вчителя підготовленого вчителя
професіонала який може передати ці
знання і вміння дітям і безумовно треба
мати нове освітнє середовище Я хочу з
вами сьогодні поділитись
нашими напрацюваннями нашим досвідом по
підготовці вчителів в умовах роботи
нової української школи адже сьогодні
фактично залишився навчальний рік третій
клас закінчив навчання по нових
стандартах 1 вересня пілотні класи цього
року 21 підуть навчатись п'ятий клас а
їх пілотних класів більше мабуть десь
140 у нас в області їх вісім які йдуть
уже нову українську школу початкову
освіту закінчили і наше завдання стоїть
продовжувати нову українську школу
початкової освіти і готувати вчителя до
роботи в умовах реалізації стандартів
базової середньої освіти тому що з 1
вересня 22-го року в усіх п'ятих класах
почнеться навчальний процес по нових
стандартах освітні по нових програмах і
це дуже складний відповідальне завдання
Отже я прошу включити відео
коротеньке на 5 хвилин і з невеличкими
коментарями
[музика]
у нас в області в сільській місцевості
50% вчителів іноземних мов викладають не
за фахом тобто він читає історію а
довантажений іноземною мовою тому саме
під час курсів коли вони приїздять до
нас вчителі ми з ними проводимо заняття
в облаштованих кабінетах де є аудіювання
де є фахівці які знають шкільну програму
і практично тут два кабінети ви бачите
які оснащені всім тим що необхідно для
якісного навчання вчителів для їхнього
професійного зростання
[музика]
бо нові стандарти передбачають нові
галузі нові інтегрований курси і все це
треба вчителя до цього підготувати він
не підготується самостійно йому треба
показати розповісти провести з ним
тренінги
це лише частина кабінетів буквально
аудиторія математики та методики
викладання Я б сказав що тут успіх от є
викладач який має досвід роботи в школі
в інституті вищій школі є прекрасний
кабінет де все є для того щоб
працювати з вчителями Ви запитаєте що
вони роблять під час занять вони
вирішують олімпіадні завдання
і це дуже важливо тому що ви бачите що
сьогодні в Україні забезпечення
вчителями математики фізики хімії ми ж
працюємо в основному сільській
місцевості з пенсіонерами сьогодні жоден
ВУЗ практично не виконує дерзамовлення
за цими спеціальностями і це дуже велика
кадрова проблема Якщо раніше
найбільшою проблемою була в нас в
області демографія і застаріла база то
сьогодні виходить практично перший план
кадрове забезпечення
цистично в нас забезпеченість
психологами
більше 50%, але в загальному хочу
попросити ви так говорите про власні
здобутки ми безумовно радіємо за вас як
директора який досяг такого рівня
матеріально-технічної і організаційної
бази ви нам скажіть а що нам робити із
дорослими які мають потребу навчатися
але скажімо не хочуть цього робити не
мають мотивації і з тих кого ви навчаєте
чи правильно я розумію це ті хто повинні
просто прийти і підвищити свій фах А є
такі хто приходять і кажуть я доросла
людина Я хочу щось змінити безумовно
сьогодні право вибору учителя піти
навчатись скажімо обрати
курси на в інституті післядипломної
освіти чи в будь-якому іншому
закладі ВУЗі чи фізичної особи
підприємства але розумієте сьогодні
в такий час коли батьки запитають у
вчителя в директора Як Ви навчили мою
дитину чому я сказав про системну мову а
якщо іноземна була буде обов'язковим
ЗНО будуть здавати і
зараховуватися як державного підсумкова
атестація нам ще треба дитину навчити
щоб її навчив фахівець і дав знання щоб
вона виходячи школи вона змогла
спілкуватись вільно англійську мову тому
безумовно можна вчитилю піти отримати
десь документ що він пройшов в курсі А
можна приїхати і дві неділі
працювати конкретно навчатись і від
цього буде значний ефект тому тут треба
щоб була свідомість відповідальність
перед дітьми перед батьками за надання
якісної освіти Ми пропонуємо наші знання
наш досвід нашого навчального матеріалу
для того щоб дати якісну освіту вчителю
який передасть потім ці знання нашим
дітям
Ось бачите от зараз є курс інтегрований
курс
природознавства він інтегрує предмет і
таке фізика хімії біологія чи готові
сьогодні вчителі викладати Цей курс на
всі готові тому що не готують такі
спеціалістів ми обладнали аудиторію і
продовжуємо обладнати обладнати і
облаштовувати і
Працюємо з вчителями щоб вони були
готові тому що старший профільні школи в
школі в класах гуманітарного напрямку
буде пропонуватись такий курс
природознавство де діти будуть
відокремлювати вивчати фізику хімію
біологію А будуть обирати цей
інтегрований курс
природничим спеціальностям як зараз
ситуація
попередник маєте на увазі підготовка
вчителів
[музика]
я ж сказав Що наприклад у нас в області
Ну ще пару років назад зараз не знаю
скажімо подрезамовленню навчалося на
математичному факультеті троє дітей троє
студентів це дуже мало це великий виклик
тому що
розумієте Чому важко зараз втримати
вчителя в сільській місцевості в зв'язку
з тим що
соціальне економічний стан ви бачите
робочих місць на селі дуже і дуже мало
Молодь не затримується
сьогодні школа приїхав молодий спів
фахівець і вчитель він приїхав в школі
сьогодні 50 дітей а через рік 35-го а ще
через рік це початкова школа і е Тому
треба працювати е з випускниками шкіл
щоб вони місцеві зацілював за цільовим
направленням іти йшли вчили і зараз іди
іде укрупнення зв'язку з адмінреформою
це дуже складні е-е завдання перед нами
це фактично виклики тому наше завдання
інститутів післядипломної освіти
максимально сприяти професійному
зростанню вчителя ми над цим працюємо
всебічно і я гадаю що успішно тому що
відгуки непогані приймайте питання П
Анатолію да дійсно ту інформацію яку ви
озвучили не так вже давно мав розмову з
Олександром співаковським це ректор
херсонського державного університету він
свого часу очолював парламентські
комітет Ну він зазначав про ну м'яко
кажучи не найкраща Ситуацію із
підготовкою зокрема вчителів математики
Ну він сам математик що і це як ми чуємо
характерно багатьох регіонів а-а колеги
і завершить плея до наших виступів
Олексій Мірошниченко виконавчий
віце-президент конфедерації роботодавців
України Я за реакцію пана Олексія
слідкував пан Олексій працює з
роботодавцями пан Олексію що ви нам
скажете наскільки сьогодні розірвані чи
не розірвані системи освіти і системи як
колись говорили народного господарства
Добрий день колеги я з вашого дозволу не
свій виступ не розіб'ю на таких три
частинки і спробую відповісти на ваше
запитання і про те що говорили наші
колеги ну перший блок - це не професійна
орієнтація і престижні професійної
освіти у нас у суспільстві за останні
мабуть десятиріччя склалась таке знаєте
стереотип що треба любую ціною отримати
вищу освіту що вища освіта - Це так
зване сексуальний ліфт який вже підніме
якісь кар'єрне зростання Я особисто мені
більше подобається терміни сексуальний
ліфта соціальна драбина тобто людина
повинна всі шаблі пройти в житті щоб
чогось досягнути це перший стереотип
відносно професійної вищої освіти другий
стереотип професійної освіти що всі
повинні бути економістами юристами
маркетологами таке інше і інше хотя коли
ми дивимося на реалії 80% безробітних в
Україні мають вищу освіту а в 2008 році
ми робили таке дослідження 42%
випускників юридичних і економічних
спеціальностей перша робоче місце
безробітні він став на облік на
Державний центр зайнятості оці
стереотипи Ми повинні змінити друге про
те що колеги говорили все ж таки ми
повинні пропагандувати
інженерне інженерні аграрні технічні
біологічні
це космічні професії ті професії де
людина себе завжди реалізує і завжди
знайде своє місце
в житті
другий момент професійно орієнтація де є
проблеми от до нас звертаються часто і
великий бізнес Допоможіть Прийти в школу
зробити урок в професійної орієнтації
розповісти про свої професії і запросити
на виробництво повірте мені не так
просто зайти в школу і тут Міністерство
освіти повинна допомогти зробити уроки
професійної орієнтації
максимальний доступ бізнесу до
профорієнтації розповісти про свої не
предмети простіше не пускають в школу а
в школу дуже важко зайти як фізично чи
директорка теж і фізично теж це треба
домовитися треба мати час
навчальний план і таке інше повірте мені
були спроби і не так Це просто зробити
друге престижність професійної освіти Я
вже говорю сформувалась така думка що
професійний світився не престижно це не
модно це не сучасна А на жаль і реалії
це підкріплюють от ми е-е говорили
Василь Григорович Шевченко відносно
розміру стипендії для учнів
професійно-технічних училищ
490 грн Вибачте все що гроші
рядом технікум коледж 960 вищий
навчальний заклад 1600 ось таких
елементарних речей починається повага до
робітничої професії таке інше тобто ми
повинні це змінити навчальні посібники
хоча вже є Вибачте в електронному
вигляді з доданою віртуальної реальністю
це все є в світі давайте все
проваджувати що дає нам оптимізм - це
останній Указ Президента відносно
розвитку професійної освіти і формування
ради яка думає збереться найближчий час
другий великий блок про який говорить
бізнес і говорили колеги навчання
протягом життя людина на ринку праці
після навчального закладу знаходиться
35-40 років
знання устарівають дуже швидко людина в
середньому за свою трудову діяльність
змінює десь 7-8 разів вид діяльності
професії Тобто вона повинна вчитися і
навчання протягом життя а я особисто іще
підкреслюю на протягом трудового життя
Людина повинна мати доступ до цієї
системи про що йде е-е на що я маю на
увазі в багатьох країнах і Європейському
Союзі Великобританії Сполучених Штатах
створення так звані
реєстр кваліфікацій тобто напрацьовано
дуже багато кваліфікацій вони є
відкритому доступі і де людина може собі
добрати якусь певну кваліфікацію вони у
вигляді чи юніків чи пазлів чи модулів
про які ми говорили і що робить
держава держава дає можливість людям
отримати цю невеличку кваліфікацію і
вона її визнає вона її визнає вона дає
відповідне свідоцтво і це є пропуском на
ринок праці це не треба вчитися рік два
три Чи п'ять ти маєш якийсь багаж ти
маєш якусь кваліфікацію добрав яку ти її
потрібно і будь ласка іде на на працю
більш того це достатньо цікавий механізм
для підтвердження освіти отримує
неформальним шляхом Навіщо тобі вчитися
під диздай
захисти свої знання отримай свідоцтво
йде на ринок праці Я думаю що нам треба
це теж максимально швидко розвивати і ще
один великий блок про який сьогодні вже
говорилося
да це державна приватна партнерство
тобто розумієте держава повинна створити
всі умови щоб і бізнесу і навчальному
закладу було взаємно вигідно працювати
до чого Я веду що податкове освітянське
трудове законодавство повинна мотивувати
інвестувати в бізнес як людину так і
навчальні заклади просто говорили колегу
данильшин тобто пожертвування які
даються вони повинні мати оподаткування
своє Якщо ти хочеш передати обладнання
спроби передати обладнання тобі
податкова багато чого розповість що матч
справа Що не маєш робити і таких багато
речей які ми повинні разом
працювати більш того зараз ви знаєте
законодавство трохи змінилося з'явились
нові форми зайнятості дистанційна робота
надомна робота таких інших будуть багато
видів е-е
зайнятості де система навчання протягом
життя повинна відіграти дуже велику роль
і тут ми готові допомагати і ще раз
дякую всім Дякуємо вам пане Олексію п
Олексію Ну з того що ви говорите по суті
попередні промовці були з однієї сторони
буряка бо це ті люди які виробляють
надають освітні послуги А ви по суті є
представником іншої сторони баракад Ви
споживаєте ці освітні послуги але що
цікаво те про що говорите і ви і ваші
колеги Це одні й ті самі абсолютно
проблемні питання одні й ті самі напрями
і від всіх вас Ми почули практично від
всіх а-а почули
слова що необхідно щоб там Міністерство
чи одне чи інше більше чули і більше
реагували тому абсолютно не резюмуючи
але мабуть трохи підсумовуючи ті тези
які ви озвучували що Ну якщо у всім нам
вам зібратися і трошки попрацювати над
підвищенням якості цієї комунікації із
державними органами і міністерствами то
як ми вже говорили можливо Наступного
року ми зустрінемося і просто за келихом
шампанського скажемо як Все добре вийшло
останнє одне слово я повністю з вами
згоден кроме одного промисловерикада
не повинно бути нема барикату є
розуміння що ми повинні працювати разом
іти на один до одного на зустріч барика
тут точно немає 100% Дякуємо вам пане
Олексію а-а колеги
Є пропозиція продовжити наше обговорення
але я кажу чиновники в робочому порядку
ви зможете поставити запитання усім
учасникам нашої панельної дискусії А ми
їм всім е-е подякуємо Це Вадим
свириденко уповноважений президента
України з питань реабілітації учасників
бойових дій п Вадима Дякуємо вам Тетяна
Сахарук генеральний директорка
глобального договору ООН в Україні пані
Тетяна Дякуємо вам Володимир рубцов
президент Міжнародного благодійного
фонду міжнародний фонд соціальної
адаптації Дякуємо вам Василь Кремень
президент Національної академії
педагогічних наук України Дякуємо вам
Анатолій залісський ректор
Чернігівського обласного інституту
післядипломної освіти педагогічної
освіти імені Ушинського Дякуємо вам і
Олексій Мірошниченко виконавчий
віце-президент конфедерації роботодавців
України
Дякуємо всім за те що взяли участь у
нашій панельній дискусії А я передаю
слово моєму колезі дмитру хоркіну Дмитре
просимо продовжуй
Дякую всім нашим глядачам і учасникам
Хочу зазначити що другий день нашого
форуму Україна 30 освіта і наука
завершується але на нашому сайті Ukraine
30.com і на YouTube каналі форуму Ви
можете бачити ще вузько-тематичні
панельні дискусії зокрема дуже цікаву
сьогоднішню яка стосувалася
бізнес-освіти завтра ми зануримося у
сферу науки університет не тільки місце
навчання але і такої винахідницької
дослідницької роботи як зробити так щоб
потім ці винаходи і дослідження були
потрібні в економіці і підприємством про
все це завтра на форумі Україна 30